NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE TO ORDER AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. AND ANY TIME WE HAVE
A QUORUM I WILL INTERRUPT
WHEREVER WE ARE. AND A CALL FOR
THE QUORUM AND I SHOULD BEFORE
I GO INTO THE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
LET ME JUST SAY ONE THING WE'RE
HAVING TROUBLE WITH THE ON
SCREEN GRAPHICS FOR THE
COMMITTEE. AND SO LET ME
ANNOUNCED NOW THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER AND THE ACCESS CODE FOR
CALLING IN AND I WOULD DO IT
AGAIN AND I WILL DO IT BEFORE
EACH ONE. SO FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. IT'S A PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AT THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. 826-815-2877.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
213-836-5713. EIGHT THREE SIX
FIVE SEVEN. AND SO- THE IN
RESPONSE AND WHAT WE GO THROUGH.
ANNOUNCEMENTS HERE. IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN AND
HEAR THE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. OUR
MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATOR WHO A MOAN
AND SENATOR STERN I SEE THAT
SENATORS STERN IS THERE SO LET
ME RECOGNIZE SENATOR STERN. AND
ASK HIM TO IDENTIFY HIMSELF AND
THE STAFF FOR THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE WITH YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AS ALWAYS FOR BEING OUR
STATE HE STAND MINUS COMMITTEE
HERE- WITH JEREMY WOLFE MY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND WE WILL DO THAT WITH
SENATOR LIMóN- WHEN SHE GETS
HERE. AND AS A REMINDER TO
SENATORS POLICEMEN MO MUTE YOUR
PHONES AND COMPUTERS WILL
GREATLY ASSIST. IN ELIMINATING-
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE. POLICE
SELECTOR ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE. AND TO
APPOINT YOUR RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK TO PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREENS. AND
STATE YOUR NAME. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
THE PUBLIC- TWO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCINGREQUIREMENTS ALLOW
BE USING- A TELECONFERENCE
SYSTEM FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY- THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE AND THEN THE
BACKUP ROOM IS TWENTY FORTY
TODAY FOR THOSE THAT WISH TO
COME INTO THE CAPITAL AND
PARTICIPATE AND LET ME JUST
REPEAT. THAT TO WERE HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THE NUMBER BEING
ON THE SCREEN SO TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE EIGHT THREE SIX
FIVE SEVEN. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIE
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. YES THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LONG
NUMBER. OF THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAY AND ONE UP ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LONG NUMBER YOU WAIT IN A
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LONG NUMBER. AND THAT TIME
YOU BEYOND MUTED AND YOU'RE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
WE WILL BE ALLOWING UP TO
FIFTEEN MINUTES. FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE ON EACH BILL. ONCE WE
HAVE A LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE IT'S JUST. PEOPLESAYING THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL. AND ONCE AGAIN FOR
THE PEOPLE. THAT WOULD BE ON
THE TELECONFERENCES SYSTEM YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE OR THERE WILL BE A
BACKGROUND NOISE. BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
HEARING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL. WELL WE
HAVE FOURTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S-
AGENDA SIX OF THOSE FOURTEEN
BILLS ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWO FOUR SIX TEN
AND TWELVE. AND A QUORUM JUST
WALKED IN THE ROOM SO LET ME
ASK- THAT THE ROLE BE CALLED.
BLAIR HERE THEY'RE HERE JONES
YOUR JONES HERE ALLEN. EGGMAN
EGGMAN HERE GROVE. HERTZBERG
HUESO- HUESO HERE LIMóN STERN.
TURNER STERN HERE THANK YOU
HAVE A QUORUM AND WHILE WE HAVE
A QUORUM HERE I MENTIONED THAT
WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON PROPOSED
CONSENT FILE ITEM ONE SB SEVEN
NINETY SIX BRADFORD FILE TO S.
B. THREE SEVENTY DODD FILE ITEM
FOR SB TWO FORTY FOUR ARCH
ALETTA FILE ITEM SIX SB SEVEN
AWAIT MELENDEZ FILE ITEM TEN SB
FOUR EIGHTEEN WIRED FILE ITEM
TWELVE SB FOUR NINETY SIX
LAYERED IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE THE CONSENT COUNTER
MOTION BY EGGMAN. WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BLARED HI
THERE HI JONES. JONES HI ALAN.
EGGMAN EGGMAN ONLINE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HUESO. HI HUESO HI
MON. STERN TURNER TURN NINE
THAT'S GREAT THAT HAS FIVE
VOTES AND WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL. WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO
FINALIZE THEM THREE. S. SIX
TWENTY SIX BY DODD OF N. TO-
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR DODD POLICE PRESENT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO START OUT BY
SAYING THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS DESCRIBED ON PAGE
FOUR IN THE ANALYSIS. SECOND I
WOULD LIKE THE COMMITTEE TO
ADOPT THE FOLLOWING ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THAT RESULTED FROM MY
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CHAIR AND
TAG. LIMIT THE USE OF- STE.
KEEP GOING OKAY. CM SLASH G. C.
N. DESIGN BUILD TO SEVEN
PROJECTS EACH IT ENSURE THAT
STATE OVERSIGHT FOR
CONSTRUCTION INSPECTION ON A
100% OF ALL THESE- SEE- G. THE
IN DESIGN BUILD PROJECTS
ADDITIONALLY CENTER STERN AND I
HAVE TALKED AND COMMIT TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF AD
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP TRANSPARENT FORTY
REQUIREMENTS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. THESE AMENDMENTS WILL
ENSURE CONTROL OVER THE NUMBER
PROJECTS CONTRACTING WORK OUT
UNDER THIS EXPANDED AUTHORITY
PROVIDED THE D. W. R. AND MOST
MORE CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE
AUTHORITY BEING GRANTED TO D.
W. R. WITH THE SAME STATE
OVERSIGHT ON INSPECTIONS.
PROVIDED THE CALTRANS. SB SIX
TWO SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
D. W. R. TO USE DESIGN BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER- THE
GENERAL CONTRACTOR PROCUREMENT
METHODS FOR PROJECT DELIVERY
FOR FACILITIES THE STATE WATER
PROJECT. EXCLUDING THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE. IT WOULD BE TO STOP
HERE BECAUSE I THINK I'D
STARTED DOING THIS C. N. G. C.
STUFF- THAT DEFINITION JUST TO
WORK. THIS IS- A CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER GENERAL CONTRACTOR
PROCUREMENT METHOD SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT MAKING THAT
CLEAR AT THE TOP. DESIGN BUILD
IS A CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
UNDER PROCESS UNDER A ONE
COUNTRY. UNDER PAGE ONE
CONTRACT IS ENTERED INTO FOR
BOTH THE DESIGN OF THE PROJECT
AS WELL AS THE CONSTRUCTION THE
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAS THE
AUTHORITY FOR PROJECTS ONLY AT
THE SALTON SEA. C. M. G. C.
INVOLVES THE SELECTION OF OCCUR
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER WHO
ADVISES THE DEPARTMENT DURING
THE DESIGN PHASE TO MAXIMIZE
EFFICIENT CONSTRUCTED BILITY.
OF THE PROJECT IN QUESTION ONCE
DESIGNED THE C. N. G. C.
PROCESS PROVIDES THE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGER A RIGHT OF
FIRST REFUSAL FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT. TOGETHER
THESE PROCESSES WILL PROVIDE D.
W. R. WITH GREATER FLEXIBILITY
IN EXPERTISE WITH CONSTRUCTING
CRITICAL WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND ACCELERATE PROJECT
COMPLETION. AUTHORIZATION FOR
DESIGN BUILD AND CMG C. WILL
HELP T. W. R. MEET THESE
DEMANDS BY PROVIDING MORE
FLEXIBLE AND EFFICIENT
CONTRACTING OPTIONS THAT WILL
ALLOW D. W. R. TO FOCUS ON ITS
CORE COMPETENCIES THEY LIST
OTHER EXPERTISE AS NEEDED FOR
THINGS LIKE OFFICER EQUIPMENT
BUILDINGS. RECREATION OR
HABITAT PROJECTS QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN RAISED AS TO WHETHER THIS
BILL WILL JUST PLACE STATE
WORKERS BUT REALLY THAT'S NOT
THE CASE D. W. R. IS CURRENTLY
PURSUING ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
EMPLOYEES ACROSS ENGINEERING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND CRAFTS
THESE EMPLOYEES WILL BE PHASED
IN OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS.
FOCUSED ON AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND MAINTENANCE ACTIVITIES.
DECIDE BUILDING C. N. G. C.
WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR GET IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY OF
WORK THAT WOULD ALREADY BE
CONTRACTED OUT. TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS
JENNIFER APPEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS IN
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. IS JEANNIE
COULD TELL ON BEHALF OF D. W.
R. AND- JUST BEFORE. WE MOVE TO
THAT AND THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
I WAS INFORMED THAT REMOTE
MEMBERS DON'T COUNT TOWARD THE
QUORUM SO WE HAVE THE REQUISITE
NUMBER FOR THE QUORUM HAS NOW
ARRIVED SO WE'RE GOING TO
RECALL THE QUORUM AND THEN
REVOKED ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LAYERED HERE THEY'RE HERE JONES
JONES HERE ALLEN EGGMAN EGGMAN
HERE GROVE. GROSS HERE
HERTZBERG HUESO. SO HERE.
PLEASE DON'T OKAY WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A CORE. NOW I'M
GONNA RECOGNIZE SENATOR
EGGMAN'S OF MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND ASKED
THAT- OF THE ROLE BE CALLED.
CONSENT CALENDARS FILE ITEM ONE
SB SEVEN NINETY SIX FILE ITEM
TO S. B. SEVEN I'M SORRY THREE
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO
FOUR FOUR FILE ITEM SIX S. B.
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT FILE ITEM TEN
S. B. FOUR ONE EIGHT AND FILE
ITEM TWELVE S. B. FOUR NINE
SIX. LAYERED BOB HI LAYERED
JONES HI JONES ALL RIGHT ALLEN
EGGMAN. EGGMAN ONLINE GROWTH
HIGH GROWTH HIGH HERTZBERG
HUESO. PLEASE SO I'D LET ALONE.
STERN. HI THANK YOU WE HAVE SIX
VOTES WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO DO
THAT SENATOR DODD AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO LEAD SUPPORT
BUT LET ME JUST REMIND EVERYONE
THAT WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE WITH
THE GRAPHICS IN THE- IN THE-
THE TELEVISION HERE SO FOR
THOSE- THOSE THAT WISH TO CALL
IN WHEN WE GET TO ME TO SEND
SUPPORTER OPPOSE TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE EIGHT THREE
SIX FIVE SEVEN. AND JENNIFER
PIERRE FROM THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS IS THE LEAD SUPPORT
AND WE HAVE JEAN COOK WELL FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WHO WILL NOT BE
SPEAKING BUT BE ABLE TO OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO LET'S
GO TO JENNIFER PIERRE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE ALL MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JENNIFER
PIERRE AND I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS MY ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS TWENTY SEVEN OF THE
TWENTY NINE PUBLIC WATER
ENTITIES THE WHOLE CONTRACTS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES FOR THE DELIVERY OF
STATE WATER PROJECT WATER.
COLLECTIVELY MY MEMBERS PROVIDE
A PORTION OF THE WATER SUPPLY
DELIVERED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF IRRIGATED LAND. THE
STATE WATER PROJECT IS A
COLLECTION OF SEVEN HUNDRED
MILES OF CANALS PIPELINES.
RESERVOIRS AND HYDROELECTRIC
POWER FACILITIES THAT DELIVER
WATER TO CUSTOMERS. THIS
COMPLEX WATER GRID IS ACTUALLY
THE LARGEST STATE OWNED AND
OPERATED WATERED WATER DELIVERY
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD. AND DR
CALIFORNIA'S QUALITY OF LIFE
AND ECONOMIC VITALITY. ADAPTING
AND UPDATING THE SIX YEAR OLD
SYSTEM IS ESSENTIAL TO BUILDING
A MORE RESILIENT WATER SUPPLY
FOR THE FUTURE. ONE THAT CAN
WITHSTAND A LONG LASTING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE
DELIVERING THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
OF CLEAN RELIABLE AND
AFFORDABLE WATER. THREE CHARGES
FOR PARTICIPATION IN THE STATE
WATER PROJECT MY MEMBERS HAVE
FUNDED AND CONTINUE TO FUND.
ALL CAPITAL PROJECTS OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT. AN EXTENSIVE
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION THAT'S
REQUIRED AS PART OF OUR PERMITS.
EFFICIENT AND TIMELY DELIVERY
OF PROJECTS AND IMPROVEMENTS TO
EXISTING FACILITIES IS CRITICAL
TO THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
AND ALL THE WATER USERS IT
REPRESENTS. THIS IS WHY I'M
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORTER SB SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR DODD. PROJECTS USING
DESIGN BUILDER THE CMG C.
PROCUREMENT METHOD CAN BEGIN
EARLIER AND AVOID DELAYS
BECAUSE OF OVERLAPPING DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION PHASES. CAN
HELP REDUCE PROJECT RISKS AND
OVERALL COST OF WATER REPAIRS.
AND WILL SUPPORT YOU TO BR AND
EXPEDITING CRITICAL WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE MAINTENANCE AND
UPGRADES. TO IMPROVE THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCY OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SUPPLY.
EXAMPLE THE PROJECT THAT COULD
UTILIZE THE TWO PROCUREMENT
METHODS AUTHORIZED IN SB SIX
TWO SIX INCLUDE. IMPROVEMENTS
THE RIVER VALVE OUTLET THE
OROVILLE DAM UPGRADE TO THE
NORTH AND SOUTH AQUINOX. WATER
NUYS INSECURITY DISABILITIES
SUBSIDENCE REPAIRS AND
UPGRADING TO POWER PLANTS. DID
YOU ARE ALSO OUT OVER A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE DAM SAFETY
PROJECTS UNDER WAY OR IN THE
QUEUE. WHICH IS THIRTY MORE
PROJECTS PLANNED THEN JUST FIVE
YEARS AGO. THERE'S SEVERAL
LARGE STATE WATER PROJECT
PROJECTS WITH ESTIMATED COST
OVER FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OR
MORE PLAN FOR THE NEXT FIVE TO
TEN YEARS. IT'S CRITICAL THAT
YOU HAVE YOUR HAVE FLEXIBILITY
TO PURSUE CONTRACTING
EFFICIENCIES TO COMPLETE THIS
WORK. DESIGN BUILD IN C. M. D.
C. WILL NOT DISPLACE THE WORK
OF EXISTING STATE EMPLOYEES.
BUT RATHER ALLOWS ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY FOR IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY
WORK THAT WOULD ALREADY BE
OUTSOURCED. AS THE B. C.
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
SIX INCLUDE ANTELOPE VALLEY
EAST KERN WATER AGENCY
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
CRESTLINE LAKE ARROWHEAD WATER
AGENCY DESERT WATER AGENCY.
KERN COUNTY. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE HOBBIT WATER
AGENCIES SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WATER
AGENCIES SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MISERABLE WATER DISTRICT AND
SANDRA GONYEA PASS WATER AGENCY
IN CLOSING I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR DODD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AND FOR INTRODUCING SB SIXTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF THE STDC IN
THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
RATEPAYERS AN AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES ARE BY THE STATE
WATER PROJECT WE ARE DRIVE A-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TODAY. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO-
FATHERS IN SUPPORT THIS IS THE
CHANCE FOR A SO CALLED ME TOO
STE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THIS HEARING ROOM THAT WISHES
TO STAND IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN ROOM. TWENTY FORTY
THREE WISHES TO SUPPORT. SEEING
NO ONE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONFERENCE ALIGNED.
877-226-8152 ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE EIGHT THREE SIX FIVE
SEVEN MODERATOR THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ANYBODY TO PAY
ME TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION IN SUPPORT. OF SB. SIX
TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE OF SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK JUST A MOMENT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE
THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MODERATOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN SENATE HEARING BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
APPRECIATE INCLUDING A COUPLE
TRYING LANGUAGE SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
FIFTY THREE. HELLO MY NAME
DENIS ALBION HE I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER AGENCY AND ENGAGE OF ALEX
M. W. D. AND WE SUPPORT. BOB
THIS. THANK YOU VERY WILL. IN
JUST A MOMENT WE'LL HAVE
ANOTHER PERSON.
THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WOULD BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
PARDON ME AGAIN MISTER
CHAIR LINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO DOWN PLACE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO A FINAL
CALL FROM NINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE ELSE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE
DELAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW
WE WILL MOVE TO. OPPOSITION AND
WE HAVE LISTED AS LEAD.
OPPOSITION A STEVE BAKER. WHO'S
FROM THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
OF CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT A WOMAN
PEG. IT IS- ORGANIZATION-
MISSED BAKER WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ASSISTING
BAKER WITH HER **** SINCE IT'S
FOR PRESERVING THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT. I'D LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR DODD D. W. R. THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE PROGRESS THAT'S BEEN MADE
ON SB SIX TWENTY SIX. WE
PROTECT PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE
THE INDEPENDENT INSPECTION
LANGUAGE BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION
INSPECTION IS INHERENTLY
GOVERNMENTAL FUNCTIONS. IT
SHOULD NOT BE COMBINED WITH THE
DESIGN BUILD OR C. N. G. C.
CONTRACT. SUPPORTS MOVING THE
BILL FROM COMMITTEE TODAY WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE
ARE STILL SOME ISSUES TO BE
RESOLVED. RELATED TO REPORTING
ON STATE STAFF AND PRIVATE
CONSULTANTS. UTILIZED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT-
NOW WILL MOVE TO ME TO LOSE IN
OPPOSITION- JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THIS HEARING
ROOM IN THAT CATEGORY. SEEING
NONE OF WILL MOVE TO A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SOON NONDA
MODERATE OR BACK TO YOU ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION
AND- AND POSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I BELIEVE THAT
LINE THIRTY NINE WANTED TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND THE OF
THE- JOINED US AGAIN HERE IF I
MAY I'M I'M GOING TO GO TO
THEIR LINE FIRST. JUST A MOMENT.
ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SH THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MASAK ABOUT GOD ON
BEHALF OF. ACTORS CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT AMEND PROVISIONS
WOULD LIKE THE BILL INCLUDES AN
INCLUSIVE PEELING SO AS NOT TO
DISCRIMINATE BETWEEN THE WORK
FORCE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. A MODERATE OR ANYONE
ELSE. IN OPPOSITION. I AM A
TEACHER WE DO HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PERSON WHO'S QUEUED UP WITH
WISHING TO SPEAK FOR PROCESSING
THE MAN RIGHT NOW JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE OF
FORTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA. WITH
INCOMES UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AS OUTLINED IN HER LETTER TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATE OR ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. YES WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE FIFTY.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RICHARD MARX AND FOR THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATE OR ANYONE ELSE. YES
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE WHAT ONE
LESS PERSON WO WISHES TO SPEAK
LINE. SIXTY ONE. AND APPARENTLY
THAT WAS- THAT WAS QUEUED UP IN
ERROR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND
MORE LET ME JUST ASK THE
AUTHOR- YOU TOOK THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YOU OFFERED
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS WHICH I
EXPECTED. WE WILL INCLUDE A
MOTION AND OPPOSITION SAID THEY
WANT TO MOVE TO BILL AND
CONTINUE WORKING YOU EXPECT TO
CONTINUE WORKING CORRECT YES
SIR GREAT OKAY AND THAT'S WHAT
I NEEDED TO KNOW. IS THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD JUST ASK IF I SHOULD MAKE
AN A OF A MOTION TO INCLUDE
THESE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
INTO THE BILL AND THEN MOVE THE
BILL YES. SO MOVED. OKAY SO THE
MOTION. IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AND THERE'S TWO GROUPS OF
AMENDMENTS WHAT WAS IN THAT
ANALYSIS AND WHAT THE AUTHOR
SAID THAT HE WOULD TAKE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS PRESENTATION
AND THAT'S WHAT'S INCLUDED. IN
THE MOTION- SAYING NO FURTHER
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION- SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
GREAT. AND WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEMS S. B.
TWO SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BLARED BY. ALL RIGHT JONES
JONES ONLINE ALLEN. EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN I'D GROWTH HIGH GROWTH
HIGH HERTZBERG. HUESO LIMóN.
STERN NINE BERNARDI BANNERS
FIVE FIVE VOTES- THAT'S ENOUGH
BUT WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT ON
CALL FOR THE OTHER FOUR MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND
ARE WE NEED. AUTHORS SO SENATOR
HER TADO YOU'RE WITHIN
LISTENING DISTANCE YOU'RE ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE SO
HOPEFULLY COULD WALK IN AND
YOUR BILL. WE'LL GIVE A MINUTE
THAT. TO A FORCED TO WORSE WE
HAVE A AUTHOR IN THE ROOM. AND
AFTER HER TADO. IS SHE WAS ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE WALL AND
SHE DID HERE SHE SHE HAS
ENTERED THE HEARING ROOM SO AS
SOON AS I GET DONE CLEANING THE
PODIUM SENATOR HER TADO YOU CAN
PERCENT SB FIVE FIVE NINE.
STANDARD OR ME JUST REMIND
EVERYONE. A WALL THE CENTER
TAUGHT US WALKING TO THE PODIUM
TO AT OUR WATER SCREEN
FUNCTION- TO PUT THE NUMBER UP
DOESN'T WORK SO TONIGHT TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
877-226-8152 ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE EIGHT THREE SIX FIVE
SEVEN. SO WITH THAT CENTER
TAUGHT A WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIRD MORNING-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE. I'M HERE
BECAUSE WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF
A GLOBAL FOOD CRISIS THAT
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ACTION. AND
MY BILL SB FIVE FIVE NINE THE
STATE WATER RESILIENCY ACT WILL
HELP PREVENT A GLOBAL
CATASTROPHE. LAST SESSION I
INTRODUCED A BILL THE SAME
NUMBER THAT REQUESTED FUNDING
TO RESTRICT THE CARRYING
CAPACITY OF THE FRAME KERN
CANAL. THAT BILL WAS ULTIMATELY
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR BUT
STARTED A LARGER CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW AND WHERE. WE SHOULD
BE SPENDING MONEY. WHEN WE HAVE
IT TO REPAIR MUCH NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN BETTER
PREPARE US FOR WATER NEEDS IN
DROUGHT. AND NON DROUGHT YEARS.
THIS CONVERSATION WAS CHAMPION
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL BY SENATOR
FEINSTEIN AND CONGRESSMAN COST
AS OFFICES. TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THIS CONVERSATION TODAY WITH
THE FEDERAL ASK THAT MIRRORS
THE ASK I BRING BEFORE YOU. TO
FUND THE CANAL CONVEYANCE FOR
REPAIRS ON THE CALIFORNIA
AQUEDUCT THE DELTA MENDOTA
CANAL ASSEMBLY WEST CANAL AND
THE FRANKLIN CANAL. THE AGING
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT MAKES
OF THESE CANALS ARE NOW
EXPERIENCE BETWEEN. A 15260%
REDUCTION OF DESIGN FLOW
CAPACITY. AT LEAST FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
AND HIGHER OPERATIONAL EMPOWER
COST. THIS HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
THREATEN THE WATER SUPPLY FOR
HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THOSE AND SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. IN
FACT OVER THIRTY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND ON THE
WATER THAT FLOWS THROUGH THESE
CANALS TO RUN THEIR HOMES. THE
FARMS AND THE BUSINESSES. OVER
THE COURSE OF TEN YEARS THE
PROJECTS WILL CREATE TWELVE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX JOBS DIRECTLY. AT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE AND
DIRECTLY. IT WILL ALSO PRESERVE
THOUSANDS MORE THAT COULD BE
LOST IF LACK OF WATER LEADS TO
FOLLOWED LANDS. TWO THIRDS OF
THE NATION'S FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES COME FROM CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA FEEDS THE WORLD A
THREAT TO OUR ABILITY TO
PRODUCE FOOD AT THE VOLUME WE
DO IS A THREAT NOT ONLY TO THE
EXISTENCE OF OUR SMALL AND
LARGE FARMS BUT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT THE EMPLOYEE AND OUR
ECONOMIC OUTPUT AS THE STATE.
AND TO THE FOOD SECURITY OF
THOSE THAT HAVE THE LEAST AMONG
US. BUT REALLY EVERYONE. SB
FIVE FIVE NINE PROVIDES IS THE
OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY TO PLAN
FOR FUTURE BUT PROTECTED AS
WELL. THIS BILL REQUEST SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION TO
FUND CANAL CONVEYANCE REPAIRS
OVER THE COURSE OF TEN YEARS.
IN THE PAST YEAR THE FRONT
WATER AUTHORITY HAS ASSEMBLED
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION. FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES AND ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION AND FEDERAL
FUNDING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
REPAIRING THE FRANKEN CANAL. SB
FIVE FIVE NINE CREATE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR THE STATE TO TAKE
ON ITS RIGHTFUL ROLE IN
PARTNERING WITH LOCAL AGENCIES
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ON
FIXING THE STATE'S WATER
CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS. SYSTEMS
THAT HELP DELIVER WATER TO
CHIEF KEY STATE POLICIES AND
GOALS FOR CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY AND
HABITATS SUPPORT. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE INVEST IN
REPAIRING THESE CANALS TODAY
CREATING NEEDED AND GOOD PAYING
JOBS SECURING ACCESS TO
DRINKING WATER FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND TRAIN OUR CAPACITY TO
REMAIN THE FOOD CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD. I ALSO WANT TO THANK. MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND FOR
BAKERSFIELD THAT'S ON THE DICE
AT THE MOMENT AND MY GOOD
FRIEND COLLEAGUE FROM- NORTH
PER CALIFORNIA BEING CO AUTHORS
OF THIS BILL AND FOR BEING
SUPPORTIVE- REFERRING TO THE
SENATOR FROM STOCKTON STOPPED
MONTHS SORRY. ENOUGH I DON'T
WANT ANYBODY ELSE TO TAKE THE
CREDIT THE FOR SOMETHING SHE
DID. I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
I HAVE JENNIFER PIERRE GENERAL
MANAGER WITH THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS RICHARD OR TAKE A
GENERAL MANAGER WITH THE
GRASSLANDS WATER DISTRICT.
GREAT THEN OF. AND THEY. WE
SOCIALLY DISTANT STRIKE NOW-
SO- LET'S BEGIN WITH RICHARD
ORTEGA FROM THE GRASSLAND WATER
DISTRICT AND THEN WE'LL HEAR
FROM JENNIFER PIERRE FROM THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
RICARDO ORTEGA GENERAL MANAGER
OF THE GRASS AND WATER DISTRICT
AND GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY I ALSO SERVE AS A BOARD
MEMBER ON THE SAN LUIS DELTA
MENDOTA WATER AUTHORITY.
COMPRISED OF TWENTY SEVEN
AGRICULTURAL MUNICIPAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER AGENCIES
THAT OPERATE THE DELTA MENDOTA
CANAL I'M PLEASED TO TESTIFY
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE NINE. THE FEDERAL DELTA
MENDOTA. IN FRONT KERN CANALS
HAVE LOST SIGNIFICANT FLOW
CAPACITY OVER THE YEARS TO LAND
SUBSIDENCE. WHICH IS IMPACTED
THE ABILITY TO RELIABLY DELIVER
WATER TO MANY SAN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY COMMUNITIES FARMS AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. THESE CAN
THESE CANALS CONVEY WATER TO
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF FARMLAND
AND THE LAST REMAINING 5% OF
WETLANDS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. THESE WEAPONS RECHARGE
AQUIFERS AND SUPPORT MILLIONS
OF MIGRATORY BIRDS AND OTHER
WILDLIFE EACH YEAR. THE GAS AND
WATER DISTRICT CONVEYS WATER TO
WILDLIFE REFUGES THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED AS- ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WETLAND ECOSYSTEMS
REMAINING IN THE AMERICAS.
WETLANDS AND WILDLIFE REQUIRE
ADEQUATE SUPPLY THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR ON A SCHEDULE MOST
BENEFICIAL TO THEM. TO TOP THE
SUBSIDENCE ALONG THESE CANALS
THREATENS THEIR ABILITY TO
HABITAT AND TO KEEP WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS HEALTHY. RESTORING
CANNELLA CAPACITY IS A CRITICAL
FIRST STEP IN BUILDING
RESILIENCY IN A CHANGING
CLIMATE. DROUGHTS ARE NOW MORE
FREQUENT LONGER LASTING AND
MORE SEVERE STORMS ARE WARMER
PRODUCE LESS NO AND MORE
FLOODING. CALIFORNIANS THE
WATER FACILITIES I CAN
RECAPTURE FLOODWATER AND
EFFICIENTLY DELIVERED TO LANDS
THAT CAN RECHARGE THE AQUIFER.
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SYSTEM IS
INTERCONNECTED AND WAS BUILT BY
A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LOCALS
THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS. SB FIVE FIVE NINE
BILLS ON THAT PARTNERSHIP BY
PROVIDING THE STATE MATCH TO A
LOCAL COMMITMENT. TO RESTORE
THE BACKBONE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CALIFORNIANS AND THE
ENVIRONMENT DEPEND ON. WHILE
ALSO CREATING SUSTAIN AND
SUSTAINING THOUSANDS OF JOBS IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I LOOK
FOR TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM- JENNIFER
PIERRE FROM THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS. THE MORNING AGAIN
AS I THINK YOU KNOW MY NAME IS
JENNIFER PIERRE THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS AND THE GENERAL
MANAGER AND WE REPRESENT TWENTY
SEVEN OF THE TWENTY NINE PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES THAT CONTRACT
WITH THE W. R. FOUR SIX- THE
FEDERAL STATE ON CANALS
IDENTIFIED IN SB FIVE FIVE NINE
ARE CRITICAL TO SUPPORT CLIMATE
CHANGE RESILIENCE BY
FACILITATING THE MOVEMENT OF
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF WATER
WHEN IT'S WET TO STORAGE NEEDS
DURING DROUGHTS THESE CANALS
PROVIDE DRINKING WATER TO OVER
THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE BAY
AREA AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
INCLUDING DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AS WELL THE
IRRIGATION WATER OVER THREE
MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND BUT
SUBSIDENCE HAS DRASTICALLY
REDUCED SUPPLY RELIABILITY AND
INCREASED ENERGY CONSUMPTION
FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE WATER
PROJECT IS ALREADY EXPERIENCING
A 33% REDUCTION OF DESIGN FLOW
CAPACITY AN ADDITIONAL FIFTEEN
TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR AND HIGHER OPERATIONAL AND
ENERGY COSTS. SUBSIDENCE DUE TO
GROUNDWATER PUMPING HAS BEEN
OCCURRING IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR NEARLY A CENTURY.
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT AFTER TWENTY
FOURTEEN WILL HELP PROTECT
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM FUTURE
SUBSIDENCE. HOWEVER THE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE DAMAGE
IMPACTS TWO THIRDS OF THE
ENTIRE STATE. INCLUDING
MILLIONS OF WATER USERS WHO DID
NOT CAUSE THE DAMAGE.
IDENTIFYING ALL THE PARTIES WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR DAMAGING
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IN SECURING
THEIR FUNDING CONTRIBUTIONS IS
A COMPLEX. AND LENGTHY
UNDERTAKING NEVERTHELESS WHERE
POSSIBLE IT REMAINS AN OPTION
FOR ASSEMBLY LOCAL FUNDING
PACKAGES. OF THE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES PAY FOR THE OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS OF THESE
CANAL SYSTEMS. THEIR BUDGETS
ARE FUNDED BY THE PEOPLE FARMS
AND BUSINESSES THAT USE THE
WATER INCLUDING WATER USERS WHO
ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DAMAGE. THE REPAIR COSTS ARE
SIMPLY TOO GREAT FOR THEM TO
BEAR ALONE- GATHER A FEDERAL
FUNDING FROM TWO COMPANION
BILLS INTRODUCED BY US SENATOR
DIANNE FEINSTEIN. AND
CONGRESSMAN JIM COSTA AND A
LOCAL CULTURE. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE CURRENT STATE BUDGET
SURPLUS AND POTENTIALLY A
CLIMATE RESILIENCY BOND TO HELP
FUND REPAIRS TO FOR THE MOST
IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE FRONT WATER
AUTHORITIES SAN LUIS DELTA
MENDOTA WATER AUTHORITY IN THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS. A LONG
LIST OF SUPPORTERS INCLUDE THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL SAVE TIME THIS
MORNING. FIRE CULTURAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA ANTELOPE VALLEY EAST
KERN WATER AGENCY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
BALLARD WATER STORAGE DISTRICT
BRANDON MESA WATER DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA COTTON JENNER'S AND
GROWERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR HIS BEER YEAH WE
HAPPEN TO HAVE THAT TIRE LISTED
ARE IN OUR SYSTEM OKAY
HOPEFULLY AROUND- I WILL JUST
STIPULATE FOR THE RECORD THAT
ALL THOSE ORGANIZATIONS EXIST
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. FOR FIVE
FIVE NINE THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE- ME TOO SORTA NAME ORGAN
AND POSITION IN SUPPORT FIRST
WE'LL GO TO THIS COMMITTEE ROOM
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
NINE. SEEING NONE WILL GO TO OF
ROOM TWENTY FORTY ANYONE THERE.
SAYING NO ONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE AND ONCE
AGAIN. THAT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE EIGHT THREE
SIX FIVE SEVEN. MODERATOR ANY
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WILL GO TO LINE FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR JOHN MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF
THE MILK PRODUCERS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. SIXTY SIX. THE MORNING
CARE NUMBERS PERSONAL HIT US ON
BEHALF OF TULARE COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE NINE
THANK YOUNG THANK YOU. FINE.
SIXTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MR
KAREN MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WHY NOT. SIXTY
SEVEN. PARDON ME GOING TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS OUR MEMBERS ERIKA DAWN
ON BEHALF OF THE ANTELOPE
VALLEY EAST KERN WATER AGENCY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN. PEOPLE I
ONLY HAVE OF THREE VALLEY MID
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BIND.
SEVENTY ONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DUNCAN MCFETRIDGE
REPRESENTING THE WESTLANDS
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IN JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE GONNA COME TO A LINE
FIFTY SIX JUST A MOMENT. MORE
THE MODERATORS DOING THAT LET
ME JUST REMIND PEOPLE THAT
SENATOR SKINNER'S THE NEXT
AUTHOR UP AND SENATOR ALAN
AFTER THAT. OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE. FIFTY SIX. AS CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU- CANDIDATE
JOB ON BEHALF OF THE KERN
COUNTY WATER AGENCYAND SAN
BERNARDINO VALLEY MISSILE UNDER
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FINE.
FIFTY THREE. PINE FIFTY THREE A
ONE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
DENNIS ALL THE ON THE ON THE
OTHER HAND INCLUDED VALLEY
WATER AGENCY SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
M. W. D. THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS THE CALPERS
USURPATION CALIFORNIA GREEN
FEES ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT SB.
FIVE FIVE NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FINE. SEVENTY
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
MIKE BELYING BUMMED OUT BY
WATER FORTY IN FULL SUPPORT OF
MEASURE FIVE FIVE NINE ACRE
CENTER HER TADO FOR HER HARD
WORK. WELCOME BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE MISTER BOLAN'S
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. BY.
SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRIS CON REPRESENTING THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BY. SEVENTY NINE. GOOD MORNING
REBEKAH BASKET ON BEHALF OF
TULARE LAKE BASIN WATER STORAGE
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA JUST MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON
JENNER'S AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WESTERN
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
AGAIN- MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN ALL TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION SO WE WANT TO GO TO.
OPPOSITION A IN THE NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION AND
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN IN THE
HEARING ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FIVE
NINE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN ROOM-
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WERE BACK TO YOU
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TWO FIVE
FIVE NINE SB FIVE FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DO
HAVE AT LEAST TWO LINES THAT
HAVE SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT PLACE.
AND
I BELIEVE I'M GOING TO ATTEMPT
TO GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN LINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE.
WHEN I GO TO LINE THIRTY KILL.
MORTGAGOR MEMBERS BRAND ALSO IS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR GETTING
A LETTER IN LATE BUT WE OPPOSE
SB FIVE FIVE NINE FOR MANY OF
THE SAME REASONS BECAUSE IN THE
PAST. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT WAS THE SIERRA CLUB-
MR LINE AB. ONE YES MY NAME IS
BELLA PASCAL AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO
CLIMATE RESTORATION. WELL
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT BILL BUT
WE WILL NOTE YOUR POSITION AND
WE'LL MOVE ON MODERATOR TO
ANYONE ELSE THAT- IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP. FIVE FIVE
NINE. SURE NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HOME TO
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO- THE
COMMITTEE AND- I WAS GOING TO
BEGIN WITH JUST A BRIEF
STATEMENT THAT I WAS GOING TO
ASK. A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR-
THE BILL SETS FORTH A STATE
CONTRIBUTION AND THEN ALSO
THERE'S A FEDERAL ONE AND THEN
THERE'S LOCAL. DOES THE BILL
MAKE THE STATE'S CONTRIBUTION
CONTINGENT ON THE OTHER TO
COMING THROUGH. I BELIEVE SO
BUT I WILL REFER TO MY EXPERT-
WHAT DOES HERE IN THE ROOM.
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CLARIFY THAT QUESTION COULD ONE
OF YOU TO GUESS TO BE THE
EXPERT WITNESS- YES THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST. STATE ALTHOUGH
THE- NO I THINK THERE'S A AND A
CONSULTANT SHAKING HIS HEAD SO
I THINK THE ISSUE IS. IT IN
PRACTICE YOU EXPECTED TO BE
CONTINGENT I WAS JUST ASKED IF
IT WAS ACTUALLY CONTINGENT
WRITTEN IN THE BILL. DO YOU
KNOW IF IT'S WRITTEN IN THE
BUILD THAT THIS. IS I THINK
PEOPLE ARE SHAKING THEIR HEADS.
HI OKAY I DO NOT KNOW. HOME
WELL MESSAGES EVEN THOUGH SOME
HAVE OF ANSWERED THAT WOULD
JUST BE A GOOD THING TO. FOR
THE AUTHOR TO DEFINITIVELY
ANSWER SOMETIME. AFTER THIS
HEARING. AND THEN MY COMMENT
WAS GOING TO BE- FROM THIS WILL
BE A CONFUSING COMMENT BUT
FIRST PART ISN'T CONFUSING AT
ALL ARE YOU DOING A GREAT JOB
OF REPRESENTING YOUR DISTRICT
AND YOUR REGION AND
CONGRATULATIONS FOR THAT THEY
WERE LUCKY TO HAVE YOU AS AN
ADVOCATE. HARM IN UNFORTUNATELY
I KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT THIS AT
THE END SO. OF THE BIG CONCERN
I HAVE A FEW OF THEM. IS THAT
WE HAVE A HISTORIC BENEFICIARY
PAYS A POLICY IN CALIFORNIA-
WATER PROJECT ITSELF WAS 97%
PAID FOR BY THE WATER USERS AND
3% BY THE STATE TAX PAPERS.
EVEN TOUGH THERE WAS A SLIGHT
AMENDMENT TO THAT IN THE- IN
THE WATER BOND IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHERE THERE WAS A
DIFFERENCE WHAT FOR LAND. AND
THIS IS A LOGICAL THING FOR THE
USERS TO PAY BECAUSE AS WAS
SAID THIRTY ONE MILLION- BUT
PEOPLE ARE SERVED WATER FROM
THIS AND THREE MILLION. ACRES
OF IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE THAT
COULD BE SPREAD OUT AND AT A
RELATIVELY LOW COST TO ALL OF
THEM OVER TIME AND CONTINUE THE
BENEFICIARY PAYS. AND I THINK
THE MARYLAND ISSUED DIVORCE
DEFEATED IN PART BECAUSE- THERE
WAS A BENEFICIARY PAYS. SORT OF
CHANGE THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THAT. AND THE- THERE'S ALSO
STATE MONEY GOING FOR FEDERAL
PROJECT WHICH I THINK IS IT IS
OF CONCERN. AND THIS BENEFITS A
SPECIFIC AREA SPECIFIC GROUP OF
PEOPLE BUT NOT EVERYBODY ALL
THE TAXPAYERS WILL DO IT AND
THE STATISTIC WAS CITED. OF THE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT CAME
FROM CALIFORNIA MORE VERY LARGE
AMOUNT COME FROM MY DISTRICT TO
THE GENERAL REGION WHETHER IT'S
PART OF OUR THE SALINAS VALLEY
BUT THEY DO NOT IMPORT WATER
AND THEY WILL NOT GET A DIME
FROM THIS BILL SO IN MANY WAYS.
IT FAVORS ONE AGRICULTURAL AREA
OVER ANOTHER AND THE REASON WE
HAD A WATER BOND WAS TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY GOT A FAIR SHARE
NOT JUST A SELECT A PART OF THE
STATE OR FOR SELECT. WATER
USERS SAID. ARE USED TO HAVE
THIS RIFF WHAT I SAID WHEN I
WAS IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
MONTEREY AND SANTA CRUZ I SAID
WE'D HAVE TO CUT OUR SCHOOLS
AND CUT OUR HEALTH CARE AND PAY
A 100% FOR OUR WATER AND THEN
USE TAX DOLLARS TO PAY FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE'S WELL. THEN FOR
EIGHT YEARS AS RESOURCES
SECRETARY I SUPPORTED THAT AND
NOW I AM BACK. TO ADVOCATING
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE DISTRICT
WANTED TO GET. A FAIR SHARE OR
SO UP FROM THAT IS OF CONCERN
AND I KNOW THAT I GOT A PUSH
BACK IN THE- SOME OF THE
LOBBYING VISITS BY THIS WILL
BENEFIT THE STATE'S ECONOMY
BECAUSE OF SILICON VALLEY AND
THE AG SECTOR. BUT IF YOU'RE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY THAT IS
NOT SERVED BY STATE OR FEDERAL
WATER YOU WERE EVEN MORE
DISADVANTAGE FOR PAYING TAXES
AND NOT GETTING ANYTHING BACK
AND SO. I BASICALLY WANT TO
GIVE THE AUTHOR CHANGED HER TO
WORK ON THIS AND SEE IF MAYBE
THERE'S AN AMENDMENT ABOUT
CONTINGENCY AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING IN IT FOR OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE STATE I'M GOING TO VOTE
TO MOVE THIS ALONG BUT I HAVE
THOSE CONCERNS AND I REALLY
WANTED TO. WIPE. THEM OUT TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY WAY. ARE THE
TO TAKE BE. SO I JUST OBLIGATED
TO ME THAT STATEMENT. OTHER COM-
SENATORS ON STORAGE ANDERSON
HAS UP HE HAD IS BUT DID HIM UP
I HAVE TO ACTUAL EMERGENCY SO
MISTER CHAIR I'M GONNA GO TO
THE DIGITAL HAND AND THEN I'M
GOING TO GO TO THE TWO HANDS IN
THE ROOM SO SENATOR START. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND I
MEAN I'M WILLING TO DEFER TO
THE DIS OVER DIGITAL IF- IF THE
MEMBERS NEED TO LEAVE SO I'LL
BE HERE FOR THE HEARING DO YOU
WANT TO CHECK. I HAVEN'T SPEAK
EVERYBODY'S OKAY KEEP GOING
OKAY GREAT- I WOULD ECHO
EVERYTHING YOU JUST SAID AND
ESPECIALLY THE NOTE ABOUT.
CENTER TIED TO YOUR RELENTLESS
ADVOCACY FOR THE COMMUNITIES
YOU REPRESENT- AND NOT JUST YOU
KNOW THE BUSINESS SIDE OF
THINGS BUT FOR REAL PEOPLE
EVERYWHERE TO STE SO I. DON'T I
REALLY RESPECT YOU BRING IN
THIS MEASURE BACK- I SHARE SOME
OF THE SAME CONCERNS ABOUT JUST
THE OVERALL FRAMEWORK HERE- IN
VENTURA COUNTY AND YOU KNOW THE
UNINCORPORATED PARTS L. A. N.
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT IT
WORRYING YOU KNOW THAT DROUGHTS
NOT HITTING AS HARD IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW BUT- THE-
WHAT MY HOPE IS IF YOU GET THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO DAVID.
YOU'LL JUST YOU'LL CONSIDER
BEFORE. THE FLOOR- YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT ARRANGEMENTS THAT
THAT. THE PORTIONS SAVE THE
BENEFICIARY QUESTION OR EVEN A
SUBSIDY AND THE SUBSIDENCE
RESPONSIBILITY QUESTION A
LITTLE MORE AND I WAS REALLY
HEARTENED BY THE WAY TO HEAR
FROM IS PIERRE- THE POTENTIAL
FEASIBILITY OF SOME OF THAT
ANALYSIS BEFORE WE- CUT THE
FINAL DEAL AND PUT THE SENATE'S
FINAL DROUGHT PACKAGE TOGETHER
AND I WOULD SAY I'M I'M OPEN
TO. TO SUPPORTING THIS BILL AT
IT AT A FUTURE DATE- IF
ESPECIALLY WE CAN GET  LITTLE
MORE THAT DATA BACK AND REALLY
UNDERSTAND- WHAT SUBSIDENCE
CAUSATION YOU KNOW HOW HOW
GRANULAR WE CAN GET IN THAT-
CAUSATION ISSUE- AND ALSO TO RE
LOOK AT THE APPORTIONMENT OF
STATE FUNDING FOR STATE
PROJECTS VERSUS FEDERAL
PROJECTS AND HOPEFULLY. FIND IT
A LITTLE MORE SURGICAL WAY TO
DEAL WITH THAT I RESPECTED
THERE'S A THIRD THIRD THIRD
SORT OF FRAMEWORK GET THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TOO SO THAT FEELS
CLEAN BUT I'D I'D LOVE TO GET
IT A LITTLE MORE TAILORED TO
THE SPECIFIC COSTS NEEDS AND
CAPACITY LOSS TO SUBSIDENCE
OVERLAID WITH THAT BENEFICIARY
PAYS PRINCIPLE- SO JUST FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. AND SENATOR
STERN- MISS PIER MOVED TO THE
MICROPHONES IF SHE'S GOING TO.
WHO WHO IS IN THAT IT IS ANY OF
THAT IN THE FORM OF A QUESTION.
IF THAT BE ALRIGHT MISS PIER I
WAS CURIOUS WITH THE
FEASIBILITY OF DOING SOME OF
THAT ANALYSIS THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT- THAT SOUNDED LIKE A VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE SIT STEP FRANKLY
TO DEFINING AND YOU KNOW REALLY
DURABLE FRAMEWORK HERE GOING
FORWARD SO JUST TAKE ANY
COMMENTS ON JUST SETTING
EXPECTATIONS OF THE ABILITY TO
ASSESS- SOME OF THAT SUBSIDENCE
CAPACITY. ISSUE YES I THINK YOU
HIS PEER THANK YOU- I WAS GONNA
JUST RESPOND THAT I THINK EVERY
YEAR THE DATA GETS BETTER AND
BETTER ABOUT WHERE THE
SUBSIDENCE REALLY IS HOW DO WE
KNOW WHAT THE ACTUAL IMPACT OF
IT IS AND THEN WHERE IT'S
COMING FROM. WE DON'T HAVE THAT
TODAY AND YOU KNOW ONE OF THE-
AS BILL AS YOU YOU TODAY IS THE-
THIS IS A CLIMB EMERGE. INTO
LAW OF WAYS THE ABILITY TO
REALLY BE RESILIENT ABOUT HOW
WE MOVE WATER AROUND THE STATE.
SO WHILE ARE VERY OPEN TO
CONTINUING TO. COLLECT THE DATA
ANALYZE THE DATA. AND TALK
ABOUT RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
VERSES BENEFICIARIES BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT OVERLAP. ENTIRELY
THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL AS WE
SEE IT TO THE WHOLE STATE SO I
THINK THE COMMITMENT IS REALLY
TO KEEP. DEVELOPING THAT
INFORMATION BUT I YOU KNOW I
DEFINITELY COULD NOT. COMMIT TO
HAVING THAT INFORMATION WITHIN
THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MR STERN'S
ON MUTE SO I THINK THAT
COMPLETES HIS SENATOR HUESO AND
THEN CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AND I'M
GONNA ON ONE ALSO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING FORWARD WITH
THIS AND BE PHYSICALLY
INHERITED A BIG MESS. AND THE
SOLUTION IS VERY DIFFICULT AND
VERY COSTLY. WE'VE BEEN SITTING
HERE FOR TEN YEARS DISCUSSING
THIS RESTORATION AND WHAT IS A
STATE DONE A RESPONSE TO A TILT
TODAY REALLY NOTHING ON THE A
SHAME- THIS IS A- IMPORTANT-
PIECE OF. OF A RESOURCE THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE ECONOMY
OF OUR STATE HEALTH FOR STATE.
AND A VERY IMPORTANT DELIVERING
DRINKING WATER TO A VERY LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF OUR STATE'S
POPULATIONS VERY SAD. THAT
WE'RE NOWHERE CLOSER TO FIXING
THIS PROBLEM THEN. SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE DISCUSSING THIS FOR
TEN YEARS WERE STILL DISCUSSING
HERE. SO YOU KNOW I. I'M
LOOKING AT THE BILL AND I SEE A
REASONABLE PROPOSAL OF. LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
THAT IS A HUGE IMPROVEMENT FROM
THE LAST BILL WHICH I ALSO
SUPPORT BECAUSE I WANT TO
SUPPORTER A FIX FOR THIS. BUT
THERE IS ALSO- THERE THERE'S
LOTS OF CONSIDERATIONS AND ONE
ONE OF THE POSITIONS OF THIS
ANALYSIS TAKES AS WELL WHOEVER
OWNS AND OPERATES IT NEEDS TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. AND IT
KIND OF ALLUDES TO THE FACT
THAT WE'RE HERE BECAUSE THEY
DID SOMETHING WRONG. AND REALLY
THIS IS THE RESULT OF YEARS AND
YEARS OF NEGLECT OF OUR WATER
TABLE HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
IS CAUSED NOT ONLY SUBSIDENCE
BUT THE REVERSAL OF THE FLOW.
OF A LOT OF THESE RIVERS THAT
ARE NOW THREATENING SPECIES
JUST BECAUSE ARE NOT FLOWING
PROPERLY AND- AND ALSO IS
CAUSING SALT WATER INTRUSION IN
CERTAIN PLACES OF THE COAST ARE
ARE THREATENING. OUR ABILITY TO
GROW FOOD IN IN THOSE AREAS
THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM. AND WE
HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO KEEP THIS
FLOW HEALTHY MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. HANSEL THIS
LIST NOT ONLY THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE AREA FRESNO COUNTY BY
SALIA AREA OF OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
WHOLE ECO SYSTEM. OF OUR ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA ESTUARY WHICH.
EXTENDS FROM LOS AND ALL THE
WAY TO MY SHASTA AND THE A
MASSIVE. ESTUARY OF- THAT'S OF.
IT'S HARD FOR ANOTHER ONE AND
WE'RE- THAT IS AS IMPORTANT A
CAN AND IN THE OF FOOD AND AS
AS AS LONG AND FOR AS A ONE IS.
SO WE HAVE TO FIND THE RESOURCE
TO MAKE WORK AND YOU KNOW JUST
WANTED. THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ONE OF THE OF
THIS I THINK THIS MISSING FROM
THIS BILL THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDED. TO SOME LEVEL OF MAKING
THIS A STATE PRIORITY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. AND USING THIS
BILL TO CALL ON THE CURRENT
PRESIDENTIAL CONGRESSIONAL. OF
THE BODIES- OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CONGRESS TO
REALLY- ACT ON. FUNDING THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF THIS. AND I THINK
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE SELECTING
DATA YOU'RE LOOKING AT DATA ONE
THING IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS STARTED TO
MANAGER GROUNDWATER IT'S GOING
TO TAKE YEARS FOR US TO MAKE IT
HEALTHY BUT WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED THAT PROCESS WHICH HAD
BEEN NEGLECTED FOR. BASICALLY
THE ENTIRE. BOB THE EXISTENCE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SINCE EIGHTEEN FIFTY. WE'VE
BEEN DIPPING INTO THAT AQUIFER
FOR SO LONG THAT IT TO THE
SUBSIDENCE IS NOT CREATE CREATE
DAMAGE BUT NOW WE'RE MANAGING
THAT. WERE ACTUALLY PAYING
FARMERS TO FLOOD THEIR FIELDS.
SO THAT THE WATER COULD. SEEP
INTO THE AQUIFER AND BATTLE.
THE ONGOING SUBSIDENCE IS
CURRENTLY THREATENING THE
VALLEY AND I THINK THAT'S ONE
POLICY THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
TOWARD THIS END. IF WE CAN.
ARREST SUBSIDENCE ANY FURTHER.
WE CAN START TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN THE SYSTEM AND-
THAT IT'LL BE WANT ONE TIME AND
INVESTMENT AND THAT THIS WILL
NOT CONTINUE FURTHER SO I THINK
A COMBINATION WITH WHAT WE'VE
DONE. WE HAVE A LOT OF A VERY
STRONG A VERY SOLID GROUND TO
STAND ON TO REQUEST MORE MONEY
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
ADD THAT TO THE BILL OR AT
LEAST A- INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION- OF A RESOLUTION TO-
ASKING FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO-
THAT. FUND THIS ISSUE I THINK
TRILLIONS ARE BEING RAISED IT
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S WHAT
I'M HEARING FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS
WORKING ON AN ECONOMIC PACKAGE
THAT WILL BRING MONEY TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS THAT
SHOULD BE HIGH ON THE LIST AND-
AND WE SHOULD- ADD THIS PROJECT
TO THE LIST OF ELIGIBLE
PROJECTS FOR THAT FUNDING
SHOULD THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACT TO DO THAT AND I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE ADDED TO THE BILL. SO
THAT THEY COULD FIND A MAJOR
PORTION OF THIS BAND AND GIVE
SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL
SHOULD THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BRING SOME OF THIS MONEY THERE
SHOULD BE SOME ADJUSTMENT TO
ALLOW THAT. MONEY TO COME IN
AND SAVE THE STATE'S OF MONEY
BECAUSE WE- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S ASSISTANCE AND WE
NEED TO ADD SOME OF THAT MONEY
COME BACK TO THE STATE SO. ONE
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS. AND I
THINK THIS WILL THIS BILL
REALLY NEEDS TO STAY ALIVE AND
MOVED FORWARD AND- AND USE THAT
AS A- AS A MEANS OF
COMMUNICATING WITH OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SAY PLEASE- GET
INVOLVED BECAUSE THIS IS
IMPORTANT PROJECT FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SENATOR GROWTH. AT THANK
YOU MATT MISTER CHAIR. I AGREE
WITH THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE JUST MADE AND- I WANT
TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND ALLOWING
ME TO CO AUTHOR IT. YOUR
PREDECESSOR WHO WORKED ON THIS
BILL- IN IT WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO IS CORRECT THAT
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE FOR OVER A DECADE- HE
SAID TEN YEARS BUT I BELIEVE
IT'S OVER A DECADE- AND IT IS
VERY FRUSTRATING. THAT WE STILL
CAN'T PROVIDE WATER TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I UNDERSTAND
THE CHAIR'S COMMENTS ABOUT-
NEARLY ENTIRE STATE PAYING FOR
THIS BUT I DISAGREE WITH THE
TEACHER'S COMMENTS ABOUT- ONLY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BENEFITS
FROM THIS. THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IS THE TOP THREE FOOD PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN THE WORLD NOT IN
THE NATION NONE OF THE STATE IN
THE WORLD. AND THESE AND WHEN
YOU SAID THAT WE ARE AND- YOU
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS THAT
WE COULD BE ON THE VERGE OF A
FOOD CRISIS. WE VERY WELL COULD
BE ON THE VERGE OF A FOOD
CRISIS THAT IS NOT DRAMATIC-
THERE ARE NONE SEVERAL
COMMODITIES- BASED ON AND
CALIFORNIA'S- THE FOOD AND DRUG
OR THE FOOD AND DRUG
ADMINISTRATION THAT. HAS BEEN
PUT OUT THAT SEVERAL
COMMODITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE PRODUCE 99% OF THEM
IN THE WORLD. THAT MEANS THAT-
IF THESE COMMODITIES GO AWAY.
AT THOSE IT'LL BE VERY HARD TO
GET THOSE THINGS AND I BELIEVE-
ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS- AS
EAT AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER
PISTACHIOS CUTIES KIWIS.
CARROTS THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF FOOD THAT IS PRODUCED
THAT ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE NATION
THE WORLD BENEFIT FROM. SO I
DON'T THINK IT'S JUST A BENEFIT
TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY. ALSO
GIVEN MY COLLEAGUE ABOUT THIS
TAKING SO LONG AND- IT TRULY IS
A BIPARTISAN ISSUE A LIKE I
SAID- CENTER VIDAK: HAD WORKED
IN THIS ISSUE. SENATOR HER
DAUGHTER WAS CHAMPION THIS
ISSUE- NOW. AS PRESIDENT TRUMP
AUTHORIZED- DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
ON THIS TWO HUNDRED SIX MILLION
IS ALREADY BEEN ATTRIBUTED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DIANNE
FEINSTEIN JIM COSTA KEVIN
MCCARTHY THIS TRULY IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE AND IT'S
AMAZING TO ME WITH ALL THESE
POWERFUL PEOPLE THAT. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE TO BE ABLE TO FIX THE
SITUATION THAT WE CAN'T EVER
SEEM TO GET IT DONE. M. SO
THERE HAS TO BE SOMETHING GOING
ON THAT WE ARE NOT AWARE AT.
THIS BILL- APPROPRIATES-
THERE'S ABOUT THERE'S MONEY
THAT NOT JUST A FRANK CURRENT
CANAL CORRECT THERE IS FOR
CANALS THAT ARE BEING FIXED
WITH THIS. INCLUDING THE DELTA
MENDOTA- SUBSIDENCE ISSUE IN
THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THERE
AND THEN ALSO. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AQUIDNECK- THERE IS
A THE SIZE ISSUE WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DELIVER WATER- IS
THE MECHANISM IS THERE IT JUST
HAS BEEN NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME IN
YOUR BILL SOLVES THAT. IN YOUR
BILL SOLVES A VERY
STRATEGICALLY FROM ONE THIRD-
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ONE THIRD OF THE RESOURCES
COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND ONE THIRD FROM
THE END USERS. I HAVE TO TELL
YOU THAT THE END USERS ARE
TAKING A HUGE RISK AGAIN AND
YOU AND I BOTH KNOW THAT. THE
END USERS PAID FOR- AGREED TO
THE WATER BOND THEY PAID FOR
AND THEY'RE PAYING FOR MORE
WATER NOW. AND THEN IS BEING
DELIVERED. IT'S LIKE GOING TO A
GROCERY STORE IN PUTTING A
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE
GROCERIES ON THE BELT. AND
WALKING OUT OF THE STORE OF TO
PAY A HUNDRED DOLLARS WITH TEN
DOLLARS WORTH OF A PRODUCT. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
OUR END USERS THEY'RE PAYING
FOR WATER THAT THEY NO LONGER
GET. AND SO THEY ARE TAKING A
RISK TO BE ABLE TO PUT UP THIS
THIRD. BUT I'M GLAD THAT
THEY'RE DOING IT AND THEY STILL
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM.
AND I THINK THAT TAKES SOMEONE
LIKE YOU TO BRING ALL THOSE
PARTIES TOGETHER. AM I KNOW YOU
HAVE GREAT RELATIONSHIPS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION I AGREE
RELATIONSHIPS. OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YOU BROUGHT THEM HE-
YOU DO THAT NOW I HAVE TOLD.
CONFIDENCE IN YOU TO DO THAT.
AND I REALLY DO BELIEVE- I
REALLY DO BELIEVE. THAT THIS
COULD BE THE TO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY. GE THE SIX. FIX AND-
THAT AND- I. EVERY AT THE TABLE
AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY IN
THE STATE THE NATION EVEN THE
WORLD BENEFIT FROM S. FIXING
THIS PROBLEM. AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE. AND LET THAT SINK
IN A LITTLE BIT THE TOP THREE
FOOD. PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD- ARE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AND DEBT WATER
THAT IS NOT JUST A SLOGAN THAT
FOOD GROWS WHERE WATER FLOWS
AND WE NEED WATER TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE THAT FOOD. THAT ALL OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS EAT. SO I
THINK YOU FOR- CHAMPION THIS I
THINK YOU- FOR WILLING TO BE
WILLING TO WORK ACROSS THE
AISLE NOT ONLY HERE BUT IN THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT YOU WERE
RIGHT THERE WORKING ACROSS THE
AISLE. DOING EVERYTHING HE
COULD TO BRING WATER TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO THANK YOU
MISTER TITLE FOR THAT AND THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'LL I WANT TO. I
WOULD SAY THAT BY I WOULD I WAS
ONE OF THE- WHO WORKED ON THAT
TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN WATER
BOND AND YOU KNOW WE HAD HIGH
HOPES THAT WAS GONNA. YEAH TO
PERHAPS MORE THAN IT DID. BUT
ONE OF THE TENANTS WE MADE A
NOTE THAT WAS ALL AREAS OF THE
STATE BE TREATED. EQUALLY OUR
WATER. THINGS GO WATER FLOWS IN
IN INFLOWS. IT COULD IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS ORIGINATE WHERE IT THE
END USES WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO ON OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I'LL BE I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY
BUT I'D LIKE TO STATE FOR THE
RECORD I AM NOT A CO AUTHOR I
THINK IT IS THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SALINAS WHO IS A CO AUTHOR
ON THE SYSTEM. THANK THANK YOU.
AND THEN JUST BEFORE. FOLLOWING
INTO CLOSE. I WOULD ADD ONE
INTERESTING THING BECAUSE IT
WAS SAID NOT MUCH HAS BEEN DONE
THAT WATER BOND- THE PARK ROAD
ALLY PRIME AGRICULTURAL AREA.
MONEY WENT FOR WATER RECYCLING
END IN THE YEAR BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC WHERE THEY HAVE SEA
WATER INTRUSION THAT CENTER
HUESO WAS TALKING ABOUT. FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MODERN TIMES
THERE WAS NO SEWAGE THAT CAME
OUT OF THE OUT FALL INTO THE
MONTEREY BAY BECAUSE THEY WERE
RECYCLING AT A HUNDRED PERCENT.
A. N. USE AGAIN AGAINST THE SEA
WATER INTRUSION AND PRIMARY
GARIA SO ALL THESE THINGS TO
FIT TOGETHER IN A- DIFFERENT
POINT. CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR COMMENTS FOR
YOUR CONCERNS FOR YOUR SUPPORT-
HI. THIS BILL AND IN GENERAL
THAT THE DISHES OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THIS IS NOT ABOUT. A RED
AMERICA BLUE AMERICA. BUT
TALKING ABOUT AMERICANS REAL
PEOPLE THAT ARE. SIGNIFICANTLY
AND HAPPEN SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED BY. THIS LACK OF
WATER- IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
I SAW FIRST HAND D. D. AND A
NON DROUGHT YEAR THE DAMAGE
THAT IT DOES TO REAL PEOPLE NOT
HAVING WATER- AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A LOT OF THAT. I EVEN NOW-
AND I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT
INVESTMENT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS AN INVESTMENT IN ALL
CALIFORNIA BUT- I BELIEVE THAT
IT STRETCHES FAR FAR BEYOND
THAT. CALIFORNIA HAS THE
ABILITY TO HELP PREVENT A
GLOBAL FOOD CRISIS IT'S VERY
REAL IT'S THIS IS NOT A JOKE-
IT'S NOT TRYING TO. EXAGGERATE
EITHER- AND YET FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU TO. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE MOTION BY
SENATOR HUESO AND BEFORE I
ASKED WITH THE ROLE BE COLD.
WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY REMOTELY
BY SENATOR LEóN SO SENATOR WE
MOAN LET ME ASK YOU WHERE YOU
ARE AND WHO'S WITH YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER EARLY MON IN SANTA
BARBARA DISTRICT OFFICE AND I
HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT IS WITH
ME IN THE OFFICE. PERFECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM FIVE
SB FIVE NINE NINE FIVE FIVE
NINE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. LAYERED HI
THERE TO ALL RIGHT JONES. JONES
ALL RIGHT ALLEN. EGGMAN EGGMAN.
GROVE GROVE HI HERTZBERG. HUESO
I'VE HUESO ALL RIGHT LIMóN.
REALLY MULLIN SB FIVE FIVE NINE
NOT LOADING. STERN. SENATOR
STERN SB FIVE FIVE NINE
ABSTAINING. OKAY A WILL FIVE
YES VOTES AND WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL FOR THE OTHER TWO ON
THE CAR THANK YOU SENATOR. FOR
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO- ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. S. B. TWENTY
SEVEN CENTER SKINNER SENATOR
SKINNER IS SOON AS THE-
PODIUM'S COINS HERE WELCOME 2%
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- SB
TWENTY SEVEN. IS ANOTHER WE USE
THESE TERMS ANOTHER TOOL IN THE
TOOL KIT BASICALLY WE TO REALLY
AVERT THE WORST ASPECTS OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DO MORE THAN JUST EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS- OUR- NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS WETLANDS FORESTS
HEALTHY SOILS THE OCEAN SO MUCH
MORE. HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
CAPTURE CARBON FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE THAT'S PART OF THEIR
LIVING CYCLE. THOSE SOLUTIONS
JUST DEAD IN THEIR NATURAL
PROCESSES ARE LOWER COST THAN
MANY OF OUR EMISSIONS REDUCTION
ACTIVITIES. AND WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW
WHERE THERE ARE MANY IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR MANY COMPANIES
THAT WANT TO FUNNEL THEIR MONEY
INTO SUPPORTING PROJECTS THEY
ARE IN WHAT WE MIGHT CALL THE
VOLUNTARY MARKET. AND THEY HAVE
BEEN SIGNING PLEDGES TO GO
CARBON NEUTRAL BY TWENTY FORTY
AHEAD OF THE PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORD COMPANIES LIKE UNILEVER
MICROSOFT IBM COCA COLA COOPER.
SO WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS FOR US TO CREATE A
VOLUNTARY REGISTRY OF SUCH
PROJECTS SO THAT. IN THE END I
WANT TO BE VERY SPECIFIC HERE
THESE THIS WOULD NOT BE
PROJECTS THAT COULD BE USED TO
MEET YOUR EIGHT COMPANIES OR AN
ENTITY STATUTORILY REQUIRED
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS NOW WE
KNOW THAT IN THE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
THERE ARE DO YOU THERE IS THE
ABILITY FOR COMPANIES TO USE
OFFSETS BUT THAT'S A VERY
FORMALIZED PRACTICE THIS BILL
DOES NOT INTERFERE WITH THAT
PRACTICE. THIS BILL IN EFFECT
WILL HELP US PREVENT
GREENWASHING CAN HELP US DIRECT
THIS PRIVATE SECTOR MONEY INTO
CALIFORNIA BY CREATING A
REGISTRY THAT. VERIFIES PROD
YOU CAN BE ON THE BALLOT MARKET
THAT WE KNOW ARE REAL AND
ACTUALLY ACT CAPTURING CARBON
ADDITIONALLY MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT DIRECTS IN ORDER TO DO THAT
IT DIRECTS OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AND A. R. B.
TO SET GOALS FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION FROM NATURAL
WORKING LANDS AND THEN
ESTABLISHING THIS VOLUNTARY
REGISTRY OF CARBON
SEQUESTRATION PROJECTS AT OPR
AND NOTICED I TOOK IT OUT OF
THE REGULATORY ENTITY BECAUSE
IT IS NOT TO BE USED TO MEET
OUR STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS- BUT
IT DOES REQUIRES. A RB TO TRACK
PROJECTS AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE
COHEN CEO OF THE CLIMATE PLAN
MIGHT MY TWO KEY WITNESSES ARE
ELLIE COHEN CEO OF THE CLIMATE
PLAN AND READ OUT IS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COM. AS MENTIONED
WE HAVE L. A. CONE FIRST AND
READ OUT A SECOND THEY'RE BOTH
ON THE CONFERENCE LINE A MISSED
CALL ON WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING SURE
LAYERED AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH MY
NAME IS ELLIE COHEN CEO OF THE
CLIMATE CENTER I AM HONORED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
SEVEN. WHICH WILL SET URGENTLY
NEEDED THEY CALL FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION ALL NATURAL
WORKING LANDS. AND HELP
CATALYZE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT. THE CRIME INSTEAD
OF THE POLICY NONPROFIT WORKING
FOR RAPID GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS AT SCALE YOU'RE A
CLIMATE SAFE CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN WHICH AIMS TO
ACCELERATE STATE CLIMATE POLICY
TIME LINE'S. ENERGY NET
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. YOU AND SCIENTIFICO. IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT TO PREVENT
DANGEROUS IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WE HAVE TO CUT EMISSIONS
IN HALF BY TWENTY THIRTY. AND
REMOVE EMISSIONS ALREADY PUT IN
THE ATMOSPHERE FROM HUMAN
ACTIVITY. NEW STUDIES SINCE
THEN SHOW WILL PASS THE ONE
POINT FIVE CELSIUS THRESHOLD OF
DANGEROUS FORMING WITHIN THE
NEXT DECADE MUCH EARLIER THAN
EXPECTED. REQUIRING XCELERATED
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS AS WELL AS
XCELERATED INVESTMENTS IN
NATURAL SEQUESTRATION. A
GROWING NUMBER OF SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES SHOW THAT NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS CAN SEQUESTER
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
ADDITIONAL CARBON WITH ADDED
BENEFITS OF HELPING OUR STATE
THE MORE RESILIENT TO EVER
WORSENING DROUGHT WILDFIRE AND
SHE LEVEL RISE. WHILE
INCREASING GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES
WATER IN AIR QUALITY
BIODIVERSITY AND FOOD SECURITY
THEY'RE ALSO NEW TECHNOLOGIES
EMERGING FOR DIRECTLY CAPTURING
CARBON FROM THE ATMOSPHERE. WE
SUPPORT SALL SCALE TESTING OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ONLY IF THEY
DO NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACT
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT I DO NOT REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS EFFORTS. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE STATE PARTNERING
WITH PRIVATE ENTITIES TO SCALE
UP INVESTMENTS CALIFORNIA BASED
CARBON SEQUESTRATION ON NATURAL
WORKING LANDS. ENSURING THAT
THESE PROGRAMS ARE AS
ACCESSIBLE TO AS MANY PRODUCERS
OF POSSIBLE AND ARE NOT. USED
AS AN ADMISSIONS OFFICER. WITH
RAPIDLY WERE CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS THE CALIFORNIA IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF A SEVERE MULTI
DECADE DROUGHT THE CLIMATE
CENTER THANK SENATOR SKINNER
FOR HER CLIMATE LEADERSHIP AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PADDOCK'S WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING SHERRY
MEMBERS READ OUT ASSEMBLY
HAPPEN TO CALIFORNIA AVOCAT
CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION. OUR MEMBERS
DEVELOPING SUPPORT INCLINATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF REGIONAL
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANS AS
WELL NATURAL COMMUNITY
CONSERVATION PLAN THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE'RE RESPONSIBLE
FOR CONSERVING MILLIONS OF
ACRES OF OPEN SPACE AND NATURAL
LANDS. AFTER LANDMARK ALSO
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
HOWEVER THESE NATURAL LANDS CAN
BE A SOLUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING SB
TWENTY SEVEN TODAY WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POLICY
BUILDING HELP STRIDES STATE AND
ITS STATE POLICIES TO SEE THAT
NATURAL LANDS ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. YOU CAN HELP THE
HABITAT IS ALSO QUITE SMART IN
ADDITION WHEN YOU PROTECT THESE
LANDS.
YOUR. THIS IS THE TIME
FOR JUST NAME OUR ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION AND SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THIS HEARING
ROOM IN SUPPORT. SIR ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
SIGNAL ONE OUR MODERATOR- THIS
IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE AND
LET ME REMIND PEOPLE SINCE OUR-
OUR VIDEO POSTING SERVICE ISN'T
WORKING IT'S. 877-226-8152
ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE EIGHT
THREE SIX FIVE SEVEN. MODERATOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AS A REMINDER
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GO TO LINE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHARITY LOTION THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU WITH THE AMENMENT
TAKEN WE'VE MOVED FROM ADMINS
NEUTRAL AND WE THINK THE
FOUNDER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE. THIRTY THREE.
SH ONE THIRTY THANK YOU. OUR
NEXT SORRY YES SORRY THANK YOU-
MISTER MODERATOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
CHEROKEE HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL THE COURT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. EIGHTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MR
JERRY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY SEVEN
BAKER THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
EIGHTY FIVE. JANET ****
PORTRAIT COULD BE SOLD CAN VARY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WHAT
THANKS TO SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
SIXTY TWO. BY MAKING IN CONCERT
WITH. YOU'RE GOING TO FIND THE
ONES THAT YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND SEE IF THEY THAT CAL
CARPENTRY CONSTRUCTION THANKS
TO SENATOR SKINNER I WANT TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB. TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUYING FIFTY. ARGUMENT JUST A
MOMENT. THE LINE FIFTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING SECURING MEMBERS
VALID ENTRY HADN'T TREATED TO
BAY AREA ACTIONS ARE GOING TO
SUPPORT CORD SB TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU FINE. EIGHTY FOUR.
THIS IS CHANDU JERRY THANK YOU
COMMITTEE ON I'M MORE. PRETTY
EVEN TRY COUNTY CRIME LAB IN
SUPPORT OF THIS- SO WITH
GRATITUDE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLIND. FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S ERIC CLAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MOTION PRO INK AND I
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. BLIND. SEVENTY EIGHT. HI
THERE THIS IS INTERVIEW SESSION
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BUT YOU
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION TO SB
TWENTY SEVEN THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION. SO WILL TAKE NINE
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM THAT WISHES TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SEEING
NO ONE WE WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SINGTEL ONE
MODERATOR THIS IS YOUR CHANCE
AGAIN ANYBODY THAT IS IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWENTY
SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION.
MONTEREY DO I ASSUME
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
SURE WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON THAT
WAS COMING FROM LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. PORTABLE
CHAIR STEAMERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS KERRY HUGHES AND I
WORK AS THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
MONITORED FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION BIO FUEL WATCH.
OUR ORGANIZATION OPPOSES THIS
BILL WE ARE CONCERNED ON MANY
LEVELS. WE ARE CONCERNED THAT A
BILL THAT CARRIES A TITLE OF
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS WOULD
ALSO CARRY SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
FOR PROMOTING UNPROVEN AND
RISKY TECHNOLOGIES LIKE DIRECT
AIR CAPTURE. IN CARBON CAPTURE
USE AND SEQUESTRATION. WHAT IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY CLEAR TO
THOSE WHO ARE LOOKING CLOSELY
AT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WITHOUT CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION AND
ALL THE HYPOTHESIZE FORMS POSES
A GROWING AND POORLY UNDERSTOOD
THREAT. TO COMMUNITIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. FOR THIS REASON WE
THINK THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT REFERS TO NEW CLEAN
INDUSTRIAL HUBS COMPLETELY
MISREPRESENTS THE TECHNOLOGY
BEING PROPOSED. THERE IS
NOTHING THAT I NECESSARILY BUT
NINE ABOUT THESE PROPOSED
INDUSTRIES MISTER HUGHES THE
HELICOPTER MACROLIDES MISTER
HUGHES THIS IS ACTUALLY THE
TIME FOR. FOR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND JUST POSITION BUT ONE WE
HAD NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
I WATCHED YOU PERCENT SO LET ME
JUST THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND ASKED THE
MODERATOR IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION IN OPPOSITION. SECURE
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MOMENT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BRING THE
MATTER BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR ACTIONS. SENATOR
EGGMAN BUT I THINK YOU I WOULD
THAT I WOULD THINK IF YOU WORK
ON THIS BILL SENATOR AND ALSO
ON THAT WORKING TO- WITH THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO ONE IS HARMED WITH
THIS AND I WOULD MOVE THE BILL
OKAY THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. SENATOR SKINNER YOU
MIGHT. END UP. PARDON STERN
HELLO I APOLOGIZE SENATOR STERN
I DIDN'T SEE OF RECOGNIZE
SENATOR STERN. I'LL BE BRIEF
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
DILIGENCE HERE AND- I THINK
YOU'VE- GOT A- SMARTER APPROACH
TO A COMPLICATED. AREA I THINK
YOU'VE EVEN OCULAR IN SOME OF
THE- CONCERNS THEY MAY BE OUT
THERE FOR THIS SORT OF FUTURE.
FACING TECHNOLOGIES IN THE
CARBON SEQUESTRATION SPACE I
DON'T THINK BUT AS TENSIONS ARE
NECESSARILY GOING TO GO AWAY
BUT I THINK IT'S- IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO TO JUST START
DOING THE MATH. AND PUT A
FRAMEWORK OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
BUILD ON SO I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY CONSTRUCTIVE VEHICLE AND
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. JUST BEFORE I ASK A
SENATOR SKINNER TO CLOSE LET ME
JUST SAY CENTER ALAN. IF YOU'RE
WITHIN EARSHOT. FILE ITEM MATE
SB FOUR THIRTY THREE HIS NEXT
UP AND WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE YOU
AND- ROOM. A SENATOR SKINNER
YOU COULD CLOSE. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND- BY WILL I THANK THE
CHAIR A REMOTE CHAIR FOR HIS
COMMENTS- THE I WANTED TO JUST
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION. QUICKLY
THE- I SHARE THE CONCERN ABOUT
WE SEE A NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES
ARE CLAIMING THAT THEY CAN-
ENGAGING CARBON CAPTURE AND
WE'VE NOT REALLY SEEN REAL
PROOF OF THAT AND SO BY NO
MEANS DO I WANT TO CREATE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE WOULD-
ALLOW FOR- QUESTIONABLE
TECHNOLOGIES WITHIN THIS
REGISTRY. AND IT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS I STATED THAT MY
PURPOSE IS TO TRY TO PREVENT
GREENWASHING. AND THAT WHAT THE
BILL THE ONE TECHNOLOGY IT DOES
REFERENCE IS SOMETHING CALLED
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE BUT DIRECT
AIR CAPTURE IS DIFFERENT THAN
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE- AND
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE THAT
MUCH OF A DEMONSTRATION OF THAT
PARTICULAR TECHNOLOGY BUT IT
MAY BE A VERY. VIABLE ONE AND
SO WE DON'T WANT TO- JUST KNOCK
IT OUT WITHOUT. IT WITHOUT IT
REALLY BEING ABLE TO SEE WHAT
ITS POTENTIAL IS BUT IT IS A
DIFFERENT DAY AND CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
SEVEN S. B. TWENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED. LAYERED
I'D JONES. JONES ALLEN HELLO HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH
HERTZBERG HUESO LIMON- LIMóN
SP TWENTY SEVEN HI LIMóN OUR
EYES STERN. SENATOR STERN SB
TWENTY SEVEN I. STERN HI OKAY
THEN AS FIVE VOTE SUCH ENOUGH
BUT WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL FOR
THE REST OF THE SENATE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR SKINNER
MOVED A FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SB FOR THIRTY THREE SENATOR
ALAN. WELCOME TO THE COMMISSION.
RUNNING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN.
VENDA HERE SIR FEBRUARY LOOKS
LIKE A ON MY PRESERVATION HERE
TO WEIGH MY COLLEAGUES- BUT I'M
GLAD YOU'RE STILL HERE MISTER
CHAIR. LET ME- LET ME JUST
START BY THINKING FATEH
COMMITTEE. FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT WAS PUT INTO THE BILL
I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE IT WILL IT
WILL IMPROVE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S ABILITY. TO
IMPLEMENT AND ENFORCE THE
COASTAL ACCESS AND PROTECT
COASTAL WETLANDS AND STREAMS
AND FORESTS. I ENDANGERED
SPECIES HABITAT AGRICULTURAL
LANDS SCENIC WATER VIEWS SAYS
LOW COST RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. DESPITE BEING
THE LEAD AGENCY TASKED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE COASTAL ACT
THE COASTAL COMMISSION STARKLY
HAS HAD LIMITED ABILITY TO
ENFORCE THE LAW. ORIGINALLY
ONLY THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL I COULD BRING A CASE
AGAINST AN ENTITY FOR VIOLATING
THE ACT IN ONLY A COURT COULD
IMPOSE MONETARY PENALTIES. THE
COURSE FOLLOWING THE MANY
REPORTS AND ANALYSES DONE BY
THE ALLEY- HIGHLIGHTING THE- A
CUMBERSOME PROCESS THAT RESULTS
IN FEW FINES AND PENALTIES
ISSUED BY THE COMMISSION. DUE
TO THE HIGH COST OF PURSUING
ENFORCEMENT THROUGH THE COURTS
IS THAT. THE ONLY- FINDING-
DEEMED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
COMMISSION WAS GRANTED LIMITED
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS VIOLATIONS ONLY
THIS IS THE PRO TIMES BUILT.
AND WAS ASKED TO REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE. SINCE THEN THE
COMMISSION WAS ABLE TO WIN THE
SO PROGRAMS BUILT- AND SINCE
THEN THE COMMISSION'S ACTUALLY
BEEN ABLE TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
RESOLVE PUBLIC ACCESS CASES THE
AVERAGE TIME REQUIRED TO CLOSE
THE CASE STRENGTH FROM THREE
YEARS TO THREE MONTHS. THE
INCENTIVE ACTUALLY WAS SO
STRONG THAT 95% OF CASES WERE
CLOSED BEFORE VOLUNTARY
COOPERATION 90% OF THOSE- WERE
WITHOUT ANY PENALTIES ISSUES
AND THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK
THAT FOLKS NEED TO. TO
RECOGNIZE- BUT HAVING. THE
ENFORCEMENT POWER. BROUGHT
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE IN A WAY
THAT THEY WEREN'T. COMING TO
THE TABLE BEFORE. AND AS I SAY
NINETY PERCENT. OF THE- OF THE
CASES WERE RESOLVED WITH
LITERALLY NO PENALTY ISSUE. SO
THIS DEMONSTRATES THAT. THIS
THREAT IS AN IS AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL FOR RESOLVING VIOLATIONS
WITHOUT LITIGATION- BUT ALSO
THERE'S THE TRACK RECORD SHOWS-
LEASE THE DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN
THAT THE THAT THE COMMISSION
CAN WORK RESPONSIBLY WITH
LANDOWNERS TO ACHIEVE RESULTS
FOR THE BENEFIT THE PUBLIC- YOU
KNOW I DO KNOW. THERE ARE SOME-
CONCERNS ABOUT THE WAY TO THE
COMMISSION DOES ITS WORK AND
CERTAINLY ONE THING I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN DOING IS WORKING
WITH. THE HOLDERS AND PEOPLE
WHO SHARE THE- HAVE THOSE
CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THE COMMISSION IS ACTING
RESPONSIBLY I DON'T WANT THEM
TO ACT IN AN IMPERIOUS MANNER
BUT- WE ALSO WE DO HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE. BECAUSE LIKE
IS A VERY IMPORTANT THING. FOR
PUBLIC ACCESS AND ALSO FOR.
NATURAL RESOURCES MANAGEMENT
AND PRESERVATION- YOU KNOW WE
DO HAVE SITUATIONS- LET'S SAY A
DEVELOPER FAILS TO COMPLY WITH
PERMIT CONDITIONS ARE
UNDERTAKES ON PERMITTED
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS BULLDOZING
WETLANDS DIVERTING DISCHARGING
INTO COASTAL STREAMS CLEARING
ENDANGERED SPECIES HABITAT TO
PROTECT YOU TO BUILD PUTTING
GREENS- YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW
THERE'S JUST SO LITTLE FEAR OF
CONSEQUENCES IN THE COMMISSION
HAS LITTLE RECOURSE. CASES EVER
MAIN RUN RESULT FOR YEARS
ALLOWING UNDER ONGOING DAMAGE
TO PUBLIC RESOURCES AND COSTING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN STAFF TIME
AND RESOURCES. FOR THIS BILL
BUILDS ON THE COMMISSION'S
EXISTING PROVEN PROCESS. TIME I
AND SO THAT YOU KNOW AND I
GUESS THE LAST THING I'LL SAY
IS THAT- THE IT SEEMS AS THOUGH
MOST OF THE CONCERNS I'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE COASTAL COMMISSION'S.
BEHAVIOR HAVE REALLY CENTERED
ON ISSUES RELATING TO PUBLI
ACCESS THIS THIS BILL DOES NOT
TOUCH UPON THAT ISSUE THE
ACTUALLY DEALS WITH EVERYTHING
ELSE IN THE IN THE COASTAL ACT
NOT PUBLIC ACCESS AND IT'S-
THINGS THAT I KNOW. SO MANY
PEOPLE IN MALIBU IN OTHER
PLACES ALONG THE COAST. SO LOVE
ABOUT THE COASTAL ACT AFFECTED
BECAUSE LIKE FOR TAX. CUTS
RESOURCES- YOU KNOW BEHIND
FLORA FAUNA ETCETERA. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IS ABLE TO. I DO
IT'S IMPORTANT WORK IN IN. IN
IN ENSURING THAT THE COASTAL
ACT IN THE PROTECTIONS IN THE
COASTAL ACT WITH REGARDS TO
WETLANDS AND FORESTS AND
ENDANGERED SPECIES HABITAT IS
ACTUALLY EFFECTUATED. NOW WITH
THAT I HAVE BEEN A BUNCH GO
HERE FROM BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION ALSO DANIEL WILSON
WITH UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN.
AND CERTAINLY ASK YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
SENATOR- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE- TO LEAD WITNESSES DURING A
BOTCHED GO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION. AND DANIEL
WILSON FROM UNITE HERE. LOCAL
ELEVEN. OUR COMMISSIONER BOSCO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND FELLOW- COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DANA BOCHCO I'M A
THREE TERM SENATE RULES A POINT
YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION I'M HERE TODAY TO
REPRESENT THE COMMISSION'S
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT PRESS BEFORE
THIRTY THREE WHICH WOULD EXPAND
OUR POWER TO LEVY FINES FOR
VIOLATIONS THAT DO NOT INVOLVE
PUBLIC ACCESS- AS- SOON AS THE
SENATOR HAS SAID. SENATE ALLEN-
WE HAVE. NOT HAD AS AS AN
AGENCY WE HAVE NOT HAD- SINUS
ALREADY PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. I AND THAT'S WHEN THE
CENTER- SPEAKER ATKINS PASSED A
BILL THAT ALLOWED US TO. IMPOSE
FINES FOR PUBLIC ACCESS
VIOLATIONS WITHIN THE SORT SIX
YEAR PERIOD CENSUS FORTY HAS TO
GRANTED TO US WE NOW HAVE
SETTLED 95% OF OUR PUBLIC
ACCESS VIOLATIONS AND WE HAVE
RESOLVED THEM INSTEAD OF IN A
THOUSAND DAYS WHICH WAS THE
AVERAGE- IT'S A HUNDRED DAYS.
SO IT'S BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AT
95% WERE. SOLVED WITH NO FINES
WHATSOEVER WE PRESENTLY HAVE
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND OPEN
UNRESOLVED VIOLATIONS WHICH ARE
NOT PUBLIC ACCESS THEY DEAL
WITH SENSITIVE HABITATS. AS IT
STANDS WITHOUT THE- VIOLATIONS-
PENALTY PROTECTION WE HAVE- NOT
THEODORO WE HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY- GET
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE TO-
NEGOTIATE AND SIX SOME OF THESE
PROBLEMS. OF THE THREE THOUSAND
OPEN- VIOLATIONS IT CAN TAKE UP
TO THREE YEARS ON AVERAGE TO.
TRY TO RESOLVE THEM AND I THE
COMMISSIONERS BEEN HERE A LONG.
TIME I'VE ACTUALLY SEEN- THE
SITUATION WHERE TO YEARS PASSED-
BEFORE WE COULD ACTUALLY GET
RESOLUTION SO I'M ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT AND VOTE I ON THIS BILL
IT IS A CRITICAL- TOOLS FOR THE
COMMISSION. TO GO FORWARD AND
MAKE SURE THAT HABITAT
PROTECTIONS- CAN BE ENFORCED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY. AND NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO DANIEL
WILSON FROM UNITE HERE LOCAL
ELEVEN. SH GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S DANIEL WILSON AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN THAT WE
REPRESENT ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA. OUR
MEMBERS THEIR HOTEL GAS AND
CLEAN ROOMS IN COASTAL RESORTS
THAT ATTRACT MILLIONS OF
VISITORS FROM AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS IS WHY WE FIGHT TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE LIKE OUR MEMBERS
CAN ALSO FOR TO VISIT THE COAT
AND ENJOY EXPRESSIONS REPORT.
WHEN FOURTEEN WORKERS FROM THE
SHORE HOTEL IN PANAMA.
TESTIFIED THE COMMISSION OF
FOOTBALL. INFORMING THEM OF THE-
CO BLACK BY. OF OUR WORK. FIVE
THE FACT THAT YOUR HOTEL THE
TRUTH BY THE- SHOULD BE IN
AFFORDABLE HOTEL IT DOES.
EXISTING THE OWNER OF BILLS AND
OTHER LUXURY IN THAT. ARE YOU
ONE OF THE AGREE BY. OF THE
COASTAL THE PUBLIC WANTS. OF
PROMISE AND NEEDED A FOR COME.
FOR NEARLY A DECADE AND A
TWENTY NINETEEN THE COMMISSION
LEVIED TOWARD FIFTEEN MILLION
FINE FOLLOWED. AND YOU TALK
ADVOCATE ALONG OUR ALLY
REQUIRED THE HOTEL REPLACE
AFFORDABLE COMEDY I HAD BEEN
LOCKED. WORKING FAMILIES THOSE
OF OUR MY WILL NOW GET THE THEY
DID. THE BECAUSE COMMUNITY LIKE
THIS OF SANTA. IT IS ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE FINISH BUT MANY
TO FIND AT THE THAT THE WERE
ABLE TO HOLD SHORE HOPE
ACCOUNTABLE. OUR MEMBERS BETTER
THAN ANYONE BUT WITHOUT
MEANINGFUL TOOL THAN FOURTH
MATCH CRITICAL LOCK WITH THE
COASTAL ACT NOT BE AFFECTED. WE
WANT TO PROTECT OUR BLOCK EGYPT
AND SENSITIVE HABITATS FROM BAD
ACTORS IN THE ECONOMIC FORCES
THAT DRIVE THEM WE NEED TO GIVE
THE COASTAL COMMISSION THE TOOL
TO TRULY PROTECT. COASTAL
ACCESS FOR EVERYONE WE URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT SB FOUR THIRTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AS WELL. AND WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO- SO
CALLED ME TOO IN SUPPORT LET ME
JUST SAY IN A MOMENT FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE EIGHT THREE
SIX FIVE SEVEN. MMHM AND SO THE
FURTHERANCE BRIEF. IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THIS CA ROOM THAT
PORSCHE TO. S. B. FOR THIRTY
THREE. SAN WILL TO TWENTY FORTY
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NONE OF MODERATOR WILL
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE CENTER
THIS IS THE TIME FOR ANYBODY TO
REGISTER SUPPORT AND WORKED AT
POINT IN THE AGENDA THAT IS
JUST NAME ORGANIZATION AND
THEIR POSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE ARE
PRESS ONE ZERO SIGNAL THAT YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT. TO
CHAIR IT APPEARS THAT NO ONE IS
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE WAS NO- WE'D
WITNESS SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO
GO TO SIMPLE NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. THERE ANYBODY IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES
DIRECT. REPRESENT OPPOSITION TO
PASS BEFORE THIRTY THREE.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO YOU THIS IS A CHANCE
FOR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR THREE THREE. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND
ONCE AGAIN WE INVITE THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE FOLKS ON
THE LINE MISTER CHAIR I DON'T
KNOW- FROM SORRY APPARENTLY
THERE ARE PEOPLE ON THE LINE
WAITING TO GET IN BUT I DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY THE PROBLEM IS SH.
BUT ANYWAY FOR. ANY AND PARDON
ME UP MISTER CHAIR- YEAH WE IT
DOES APPEAR THAT BUT WE DO HAVE
BUT MORE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. IF YOU LIKE WE CAN
RETURN TO THE SUPPORT GROUP
FIRST BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE
OPPOSITION GROUP DISCO OR WE
CAN JUST PUT THE MEN ONLY
COMMENTS JUST GO
INDISCRIMINATELY TO ANYBODY
THAT IS SIGNALED THEY WANT TO
SPEAK UNTIL YOU'RE DONE. AND
THEY CAN EITHER BE A SLUR
AGAINST. OKAY GOING TO GO TO
LINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE OF THE NEURAL WITHOUT
ABOUT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN ADDITION.
LINE. ONE OH SIX. THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBER NUMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THE RECALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE ONE
OH EIGHT. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBER ONE SINGLE GIRL ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
KNOW WHAT. HI THIS IS FRONTIER
COOKING FROM OCEANIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU HI CYNTHIA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CALL. LINE. NINETY
THREE. A GOOD MORNING CLEVELAND
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COULD KEEPER ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE FIFTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
KASHIN NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF-
CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE. ONE ELEVEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LINE NINETY
FIVE. MY NAME IS RENEE I USED
WITH THE HARBOR AND BEACH
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE FROM OXNARD
AND VENTURA COUNTY WE STAND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHAT LINE. FORTY FIVE. PART
GOOD FOR A WOMAN. OUR. ONE
CANCELLARA- DO YOU HAVE A
POSITION. YEAH STAR ONE FORMER
CHAIR OF THE COASTAL COMMISSION
AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN ALLIANCE FOR NATURE
IT'S IMPORTANT VERY IMPORTANT
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FIND ONE FOR CLEAN. HELLO
THIS IS ROCHELLE TURKEY
RESIDENT OF SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
THREE THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. ONE FIFTEEN. HI IT'S
MERRY JACK WHICH CITIZENS
PRESERVING MANAGED CALLING INTO
COURT AS S. B. FOUR THREE THREE
THANKS SENATOR ALAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE MINUTE ONE NO.
NINE HELLO THIS IS DONE THE
LAST BEING- THE FANS CANNOT
COUNTY. I'M A VERY MUCH
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FOUR TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. IT.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON THAT WITH THE
SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK WITH
AN OPERATOR JUST A MOMENT.
BLIND. ONE SIXTEEN. WHY WOULD
TO CONTINUE ONE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS LAUREN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA CALLING ON
SUPPORTERS SB FOUR THIRTY THREE
THIS IS AN ISSUE THE OPERATOR
LINES I'M ALSO GOING TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR NATIONAL
PARKS CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
PRESERVE CALAVERA YOU CAN
CONFIRM BY MENTAL RIGHT
FOUNDATION COULD TALK. THE BILL
MARK J. OSUNDEFENDER COLLECTOR
IN TWO WORDS FROM THE HARVARD
BEACHES AND PARKS CALIFORNIA
COULD PEOPLE ALLIANCE AND
FRIEND COMMITTEE A LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MINE NINETIES.
HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS MARIN
SO- YOU CHAIR OF ST PETER NAY
CAN FOR LAND USE CHAIR AND THEN
IT NEIGHBOR CAN BUT IN SPEAKING
BEHALF OF CITY PERSONAL BENNETT
IN LAST. PLEASE SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO MAY HAVE-
STILL WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS
TIME BUT REMOVED YOURSELF FROM
THE COMMENTS Q. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MODERATOR TO HAVE A YOUNG CHILD
WITH YOU. THE TEACHER I DO NOT
I APOLOGIZE THAT WAS FROM THE-
PREVIOUS CALLER JUST A MOMENT.
THAT'S LIKE A TOTAL
MICROAGGRESSION. GO GO TO LINE.
ONE OH TWO SEVEN. HI THIS IS
JENNIFER BABBAGE FROM THE THIRD
BY COUNTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT BEGINS FACT CHECKING INTO
COURT AUTHORED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
INFORMATION CENTER AT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CENTER AT SAN
DIEGO NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT
SOCIETY IN STATE AUDUBON
SOCIETY BACK INTO DEBATE THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL RESPONSIBILITY
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE ENACT
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE WILD HAS
AN EXTENDED THE AUDUBON SOCIETY
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE ONE OF. ASK. I DON'T KNOW
FIVE YOUR LINES OPEN. LINE ONE
OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO WE'RE HERE LINE ITSELF
BUT- THANK YOU AND I THE FIRST
TIME IN DOING THIS CONFUSED
ABOUT HOW TO HOW WE THINK WE
SHE A FEW PARTICIPATING. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN MY
NAME IS KATHY B. ALLEN I'M
REPRESENTING CITIZENS PROTEST
WATER AND WE ABSOLUTELY
APPROVED. REPORT THIS ORDINANCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENT.
SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE WOULD
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THE- THE
BILL BACK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
OUR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR'S
GONNA TAKE SOME AMENDMENTS-
THEY'RE GONNA SPEAK TO DUE
PROCESS AND I WAS JUST
WONDERING IF- THE AUTHOR WOULD
CARE TO SPEAK TO THAT AND-
EXPLAINED WHAT THAT HOW MAY NOT
BE JUST CLARIFY AUTHOR THESE
ARE THE AMENDMENTS YOU SAID
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR STATEMENT YES
I AM I AM I AM I THOUGHT
SUCCESSFULLY AMENDMENTS AND SO-
ON. OKAY SO THE BILL DOES ON
THE DUE PROCESS TO ASSIGNMENTS
IT'S AN IMPORTANT TIME THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT OUT OF THE
BILL PROVIDES FOR A SIXTY DAY
GRACE PERIOD FOR VIOLATORS. TO
VOLUNTARILY. RESOLVE VIOLATIONS
WITH NO PENALTY- A VOTE OF THE
FOR COMMISSION. THE NEW PUBLIC
HEARING ORDER TO ASSESS THE
PENALTY AND IT'S ALL DONE
ACCORDING TO BAGLEY KEENE- DUE
PROCESS PROTECTIONS TO ALLEGED
VIOLATORS- THAT INCLUDES A
JUDICIAL REVIEW- IN THE
DEPOSITION OF ALL FINES INTO
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S
VIOLATION REMEDIATION ACT WHICH
IS THAT USED TO SUPPORT.
RESTORATION AND PRESERVATION
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS AS
OPPOSED TO SO IT DOESN'T IT'S A
VERY- CONFINED FIVE AND THERE
WAS CONCERN IN THE PAST THAT. I
WAS GOING INTO A GENERAL FUND
IN THAT THERE WAS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND SO THIS IS- THAT'S
RESOLVED THROUGH. THROUGH THE
SPECIAL ACCOUNT THAT'S BEEN
THAT'S BEEN CREATED- SO THE SO
THERE IS A YES AND IT IN INTO
THE CITY COPY TO- WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS ON ON ON
FURTHER DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS
IF THAT'S OF INTEREST. THANK
YOU AND YOU KNOW ON THE NOTE
OF. EACH ONE OF YOUR-
SUPPORTING WITNESSES MENTIONED
THAT THERE'S THREE THOUSAND
OUTSTANDING CASES. FIVE I HEARD
THAT CORRECTLY- IF THIS BILL
PASSES IS THERE KIND OF ANY.
FILE I'M HOW LONG IT'LL TAKE TO
CLEAN THOSE UP CLEAR THOSE UP.
YES TO THE ISSUE I'VE BUT
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT WHEN
THE PROTEST AND ARMS WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE PRO
TEM'S BILL THIS IS THE BILL.
THAT WAS PASSED BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN- THE- THE ACT OF
GIVING THEM. HE HAS A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND FOR GOOD FORTUNE
PACKAGE LITTLE IT WAS JUST IT
WAS STILL IT WAS IT HAD TO BE
DONE BY THE AG I MEAN THE VA G.
POLICE THE- THE ACT AND IT WAS
JUST A ABSOLUTE IMPOSSIBILITY
THE AG JUST DIDN'T HAVE THE
BANDWIDTH. SO GIVING THEM THIS
ENFORCEMENT POWER. DRAMATICALLY
IN DEBT. INCREASED COMPLIANCE-
TO THE PUBLIC FOR THE PUBLIC
ACCESS QUESTIONS OF THE TO
LITERALLY 95% OF THE- CASES
WERE CLOSE WITH FULL VOLUNTARY
COOPERATION. ON BOTH SIDES 90%
OF THEM HOW WERE ISSUED WE'RE
DONE WITH NO PENALTIES ISSUED.
THE STATE A LOT OF MONEY ON
LITIGATION. I RECEIVED A LOT OF
TIME THE CASES WENT FROM BEING
RESOLVED IN THREE YEARS TO
THREE MONTHS THE AVERAGE. SO-
YOU KNOW THE ISSUE RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE IS THIS IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO BASICALLY I MEAN I YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS THE CASE
THEY JUST THEY JUST KNOW THAT
THE BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
DOESN'T HAVE THE REAL POWER TO-
AND- WHEN PUSH COMES TO SHOVE
TO ENFORCE SOME OF THESE
VIOLATIONS AND- AND SO FOLKS
DISCOUNT ON THE GO POUND SAND
AND THERE'S JUST NOT A LOT THAT
CAN BE DONEIN THESE THINGS AND
GETTING STUCK. IN YEARS AND
YEARS OF- OF DEBATING AND BY
THE WAY THE WHAT THE OTHER
QUESTION TO THE OTHER POINT TO
BRING UP SOMETIMES THESE THINGS
TO GO TO COURT AND THERE WAS A
RECENT COURT CASE WHERE THE
COURT AND SAID IT IS ACTUALLY
MENTIONED IN- ON ON PAGES FOUR
AND FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS- IT
WAS A CASE WHERE. WAS A BIG.
RENT FOR THE STRUCTURES THAT.
BUILT THAT IMPEDED PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE BEACH IN
VIOLATION OF THE OF THE COASTAL
ACT AND- YOU KNOW THE- THE-
SERVICE WAS DONE THIS IS THIS
IS ALL HAPPENING LONG BEFORE.
LONG BEFORE THE BILL HAPPEN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND YOU KNOW.
THE LAND THE LAND OWNER WHO
WINNER WAS BASICALLY RENTING
OUT A PROPERTY FOUR THOUSAND
BUCKS AND I CALLING IT A
PRIVATE BEACH. AND CLEAR
VIOLATION THE COASTAL ACTIVITY
BASICALLY TOLD THE CHEMICALS
LIKE TO GO POUND SAND AND
EVENTUALLY OF COURSE THE
LEGISLATION CHANGE THEY HAD
THEY HAD SOME MORE ENFORCEMENT
POWER IN THIS WAS THE END OF
THIS WENT TO COURT. AND THE
COURT ACTUALLY FOUND NOT ONLY
FOR THE GOAL SOUNDS AND WITH
THE BEACH TERM YES EXACTLY- OF
THE PLAN WAS INTENDED RIGHT.
HEY. BUT HE DIDN'T THE YOU KNOW
THE EVENTS THE OTHER KEY THING
IN THE COURT CASES THAT THEY
FOUND- THE COURT THAT THE
APPEALS COURT ACTUALLY WENT TO
APPEALS COURT AND THEY
DETERMINED THAT- THAT THERE WAS
A SUBSTANTIAL DUE PROCESS
ASSOCIATED WITH BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION'S APPROACH AND
SENATOR JONES WAS AT RESPONSIVE
TO YOUR QUESTION I THINK SO
YES. OKAY THANK YOU. OTHER OR
COMMENTS. GOVERNMENTS ARE
APOLOGIZE AGAIN SENATOR STERN
I'M GONNA GO RIGHT TO YOU.
THANKS MISTER CHAIR- GOOD THE
CALLING WE APPRECIATE AT THE
GATES AND I JUST WANT TO THANK.
I KNOW THE AUTHOR- STRETCHED
HERE AND DUG IN WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND- THE EXTENSIVE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU SEE IN THE
ANALYSIS- ARE THE PRODUCT OF. A
S. LONG SERIES OF DISCUSSIONS
TO TRY TO PUT A FRAMEWORK
TOGETHER HERE THAT. THAT ISN'T
JUST TAILORED TO A PUBLIC
ACCESS VIOLATION WHICH WAS THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THE BILL
BUT REALLY TAILORED TO THESE
OTHER. KINDS OF IMPACTS. YOU
KNOW DUMPING ON BEACHES OR
DAMAGE TO ENVIRONMENT SENSITIVE
HABITAT- OR SEEN MINING MAYBE
NOT COUNTING OF SAND BUT MINING
OF SAND AND THE REALLY
EGREGIOUS VIOLATION SO I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT AN
ADDITIONAL INTO YOUR YOUR-
EFFORT ON ENSURING THERE'S-
MISTER DUE PROCESS AND A FAIR
PROCESS HERE. THROUGH THE
LEGISLATION AND THAT'S ALSO
DEALING WITH THE DOUBLE
JEOPARDY ISSUE AS WELL AS THE
CURE PERIOD BEING EXTENDED TO
SIXTY DAYS- AND THE RIGHT TO
APPEAL OBVIOUSLY BUT THE OTHER
KEY ELEMENTS THERE WE
APPRECIATE. YOU ALL AND YOUR
SUPPORTERS FOR MEETING US ON
OUR PRESERVING ALSO THE ABILITY
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DO
BUILDING CODE ENFORCEMENT ON
THEIR OWN AND I THINK THAT'S
OFTEN WHEN WE GET SOME OF THE
BEST OUTCOMES IS WHERE THE
SMALLER VIOLATIONS. ARE DEALT
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT BY WITH
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
ANYONE ELSE E. P. N. AND OTHER
CODES THAT THEY CAN FORCE MORE
NAME BILLION THAT HAVE THE
COASTAL COMMISSION GO AFTER.
THE BIG THINGS THAT SORT OF
DEFIANT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABILITY TO. TO DO THE JOB HERE-
SO THANKS FOR MAKING ALL THOSE-
AND IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL
AND I. I I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. BOB
THANK YOU SENATE STERN PROMISES
SHARE PRICE WITH THE COMMON AND
JUST ALSO SAID. THAT MAKE MARK
AND UP. THAT GOT A HOLD OF WAS
IN MY SENATE DISTRICT WHERE.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OUTCOME. SO SEEING NO ONE ELSE
SEEKING TO BE RECOGNIZED-
SENATOR YOU MAKE CLOTHES NOT
JUST A FEW OF THE CITY REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE WORK WITH
THAT WITH THE CHAIR AND AT YOU
KNOW AND I WILL SAY YOU KNOW
CHAIR REPRESENTS A- COASTAL
DISTRICT JUST AS I DO I BUT ALL
THE COASTAL DISTRICT. THAT IS
FAR MORE RURAL THAN MINE. AND I
THINK YOU KNOW HIS FOLKS IN HIS
DISTRICT OF HAD. AWESOME
CHALLENGES WITH THE COASTAL
COMMISSION- SOME A VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S WORK SO IT'S A MIX
IT'S KIND OF SIMILAR TO CENTER
LAIRD'S DISTRICT. IN THAT
RESPECT AND SO WE WORK HARD
TOGETHER TO GET THE BILL TO A
PLACE WHERE WE'RE BEING
RESPECTFUL OF. LANDOWNERS AND-
AND FOLKS ON THE GROUND AND
INTO COASTAL COMMUNITIES WHILE
ALSO AT THE SAME TIME. HI
MAKING SURE THAT THE- WEEK WE
GIVE THE COASTAL COMMISSION THE
TOOLS IT NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT
THE COST ELECT ISRAEL. THAT THE
PROTECTIONS AND PROVISIONS IN
THE COASTAL ACT THAT CONTINUE
TO BE INCREDIBLY POPULAR AROUND
THE STATE. REALLY TREASURED
AROUND THE STATE. ARE ARE ARE
MADE REAL AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT
AND WITH THAT IN THAT SPIRIT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. RIGHT
TO SERVE ANYONE THAT HAS A
MOTION. MOTION BY A CENTURY
EGGMAN WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM EIGHT S. B.
FOUR THREE THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED BY
LAYERED I'D JONES JONES ALL
RIGHT ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN EGGMAN ONLINE GROWTH
HIGH GROWTH HIGH HERTZBERG
HUESO LOAN. SENATOR LEE MALONE
SP FOUR THREE THREE HI THE MOON
ON A STERN. TENER STERN IS
BEFORE THREE THREE AYE STERN HI
THAT THE BILL WS SEVEN VOTES
AND WE WILL PUT IT ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE- SENATOR JONES S. B. TWO
TWO SEVEN AND YOU CAN PERCENT
FROM YOU THE DALLAS SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
SEVEN CREATES A NARROWLY
TAILORED REGISTRATION PROGRAM
FOR COMPETITION OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES. THIS BILL IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF MY BILL FROM
LAST YEAR S. B. TEN TWENTY FOUR
TEN TWENTY FOUR PASSED OUT OF
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION OFF
THE SENATE FLOOR. LAST YEAR ON
CONSENT IN A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
OUT OF TURN US IN
TRANSPORTATION THIS YEAR THE
BILL PASSED OFF THE ASSEMBLY
FOR MIDNIGHT AND US ON THE LAST
NIGHT OF THE SESSION AND
UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T HAVE TIME
TO COME BACK TO THE SENATE.
CONCURRENCE FOR FINAL VOTE OR
WOULD HAVE BEEN- WRAPPED UP
LAST YEAR I THINK- I'M RUNNING
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND- THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CURRENTLY COMPETITION OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLES ARE REGISTERED
TO CARDS RED STICKER PROGRAM.
TWO YEARS AGO CARD DECIDED THE
IN THIS TICKET RED CIRCLE
PROGRAM IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND NO OTHER AGENCY AT THAT
TIME PUT TOGETHER A PLAN TO
REPLACE THE PROGRAM. WITHOUT A
NEW PROGRAM- OHB COMPETITIONS
AND PRACTICE WRITING BELIEVE
PUT TO AN END ON CALIFORNIA
LANDS. ADDITIONALLY LOCAL
ECONOMIES THAT RELY ON THE
SPORT WOULD BE DECIMATED BY A
MULTI MILLION DOLLAR REVENUE
LOSS. IN ORDER TO SAVE A LOT OF
SPORT WITH A LONG HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL CREATES A
REPLACEMENT REGISTRATION
PROGRAM. THROUGH THE PARKS
DEPARTMENT. BY OFFICE HAS SPENT
OVER A YEAR WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING O. H. V.
COMPETITION ORGANIZATIONS- H.
B. MANUFACTURERS AND SEVERAL
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING PARKS
DMV AND CAR. ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
BEEN REACHING OUT TO MY MIDDLE
OPPOSITION FOR MONTHS WE'VE
FINALLY BEEN ABLE TO SET UP A
MEETING WHICH WILL HAPPEN NEXT
WEEK. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A CONSTRUCTIVE MEETING
WITH HE- WITH THE FOLKS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION. I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH CARP SINCE
LAST SESSION AND HAVE ADDRESS
TO THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS. IN FACT THIS BILL IS
SO NARROWLY TAILORED ELIMINATES
NEARLY 93% OF NEW COMPETITION
VEHICLES. BECAUSE OF THIS BILL
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON MULTIPLE
FACETS OF THE STATE THE BILL
ENJOYS STRONG SUPPORT FROM THE
OHB COMMUNITY BUSINESSES AND
SEVERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS. I HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES TODAY- MISTER
CHAIR JAMES LOMBARDO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
ASSOCIATION BY BELIEVES HERE IN
THE ROOM. ANNA TERRY MCHALE
WITH THE COALITION FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS THANK YOU SENATOR SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE TO
LEAD SUPPORT WENT ASSIST LET'S
GO TO THE ONE IN THE ROOM
FIRST. JAMES ON BARDO
CALIFORNIA MOTORCYCLE OR MOTOR
CYCLE DEALERS ASSOCIATION AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO TERRY MCHALE
FROM THE COALITION FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS THE OF RIGHT THERE UNDER
THAT MICROPHONE. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE IS TO CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JAMES ANBAR
HAPPY AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTS OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS IN THE
STATE- COVERED HIT US IT ISN'T
JUST THE RESTAURANTS AND- OTHER
BUSINESSES IT REALLY HIT THE
MOTORCYCLE INDUSTRY. OUR SHOW
ROOMS WERE SHUT DOWN FOR SIX
MONTHS WE COULD ONLY DO-
REPAIRS AND PARTS. AND IT WAS
REALLY DEVASTATING- THEN THEY
RE OPEN TOMORROW LIMITED TO TEN
OR MORE PEOPLE AND SO PEOPLE
ARE STARTING TO COME BACK INTO
THE SHOPS. AND TRYING TO
PURCHASE MOTORCYCLES- THIS WE
WORK WITH THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD FOR OVER THREE YEARS TO
DEVELOP THAT PROGRAM THAT
FINALLY ELIMINATE THAT THE RED
STICKER. FOR PERSONAL USE BUT
THE- RACING VEHICLES WERE
PROTECTED- THAT SINCE SICK THEY
CAN'T REGULATE THAT WITH THIS
BILL CLARIFIES THE PRACTICE
THAT WE CAN PRACTICE IN THESE
THINGS- I WAS AT BUFFALO BILLS
ON THE ON THE STATE LINE MONDAY
AS WE WENT OUT THE PARKING LOT
THERE WERE THESE. DUNE BUGGIES
OF RACING AROUND THE PARKING
LOT NASA PERSON WHAT WAS THIS
FOR HE SAID THIS IS HOW THAT
THEY PRACTICE TO BECOME A TRANS
AM. DRIVER IN LAGUNA SECA OR
LONG BEACH GRAND PRIX- THESE
BIKES COST BETWEEN TWELVE AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO
IT'S NICE TO FOR ME TO CLOSE
OUT PURCHASES WHEN THESE THEY
BY THE BODY ARMOR JUST ANOTHER
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND SO
THE ECONOMIC POLICY SOME TIME
FOR THE OTHER WITNESSES
ECONOMIC HIT TO THE CAT
MOTORCYCLE INDUSTRIES ABOUT
TWENTY SIX POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. THAT'S BECAUSE THEY
PURCHASED MORE THAN ONE BIKE
AND MULTIPLE- PART SIX CENTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE. AND WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO. BUDGETARY MCHALE FROM
THE COALITION FOR PUBLIC ACCESS.
WHO WAS ON THE CONFERENCE LINE.
WELCOME TO THE- UP. WELL THANK
YOU TO CHAMBERS WITH THEIR SO
SEE IF YOU HAD THE OFF- EXCEPT
FINALLY BILL AND BE IN IS
THAT'S OKAY I STEPPED BORN NO
JUST TAKE THE JUMP OFF AS A IS
ALWAYS PA AND THEN ALLOW YOU.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CLICHE. AGAINST THAT RIGHT
THERE IN READING THIS AND WORK
A COUPLE OF ALL HIGHWAY. YOU
KNOW OKAY FIFTY YEARS AGO THIS
IS- WHICH WE DIVISION WOULD
CREATE IN PART. IT IS CREATED
FOR THE- PURPOSE. THIS BILL HAS
BEEN INTRODUCED SO THAT
ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN WHICH THE
RECREATION CAN TAKE PLACE IN AN
ENVIRONMENT FOSTERING
RESPONSIBILITY ACCOUNTABILITY
AND MITIGATION. THIS
LEGISLATION WAS WRITTEN WITH
TWO YEARS OF INPUT BY PARKS AND
REPRESENTS WHAT WE BELIEVE TO
BE NECESSARY TO ALLOW FOR
COMPETITION FOR COMPLETION
COMPETITION WRITING- IN
CALIFORNIA THE BILL DOES NOT
EXPAND AND EMBATTLED- EACH P.
PROGRAM BEYOND WHAT IT IS TODAY
THIS BILL WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF NON
COMPLIANT VEHICLES AND PUTS IN
PLACE A SYSTEM THAT GENERATES
LEADS TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT. REGULATE
TRAINEESHIP TO RESTRICTED AND
CONTROLLED AREAS. THOSE WHO
WANT TO USE A VERY SMALL
PORTION OF OUR EXTRAORDINARY
PARK SYSTEM TO COMPETE. WE
ACTUALLY LIVE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT NOW
WE'RE GOING. TO- THOSE SO
CALLED ME TOO SECTION NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION AND
THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF FOR S. B.
TWO TWENTY SEVEN IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THAT WISHES TO STAND IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL THEN GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR- THIS IS THE TIME FOR
ME TO SEND SUPPORT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE THEN DURING THIS
TIME. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL. NOW GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FOUR. PARDON ME JUST A
MOMENT. WHEN YOU GO TO LINE.
THIRTEEN GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRED ON AMADOR WITH AMA
DISTRICT THIRTY SIXTEEN QUITE
WARRIOR RACING WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BLIND. ONE TWENTY
FOUR. TWENTY FOUR PARDON ME
THIS IS BOBBY MCCALL THE
WITHOUT MADERA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR TOM WHEELER CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BLIND SEVENTEEN A
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STERN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS NICHOLAS HARRIS WESTERN
STATES REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
AMERICAN MOTORCYCLIST
ASSOCIATION IN FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
TWENTY TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS
KEVIN TOLD FOUR I LIVE IN LEWIS
CALIFORNIA I'M AN AVID CYCLIST
MOTORCYCLIST WHO AND I HAVE NOT
SUPPORTER OF S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE TWENTY THREE.
POACHER MEMBERS TIM BELCHER ON
BEHALF OF BETA MOTORCYCLES IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE TWENTY
NINE. ABOUT CHRISTOPHER CARTER
PATROL VALLEY CALIFORNIA I AM
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HAVE A
MOTORCYCLE FOR FIFTY YEARS AN
EMPLOYEE FIFTEEN. PEOPLE THAT
ARE DEPENDENT ON OFFROAD
RECREATION. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY. KEEP. ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINES OPEN- THIS IS SUSAN
JOHNSON FROM SIERRA MOTOR
SPORTS AT A DEALERSHIP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE-
TEN EMPLOYEES AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FIFTY CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE WOULD SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK TO YOU
IN A MOMENT. BY THIS IS THAT
TIME FOR OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE
ONE LEAD OPPOSITION- WITNESS ON
THE CONFERENCE LINE DANIEL
BARRETT FROM THE SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA
AND ARE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
STATEWIDE. IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO TWO SEVEN WHICH WOULD
UNNECESSARILY ALLOW. FOR
CONTINUED EXPANDED YEARS OF
HIGHLY POLLUTING VEHICLES ON
PUBLIC LANDS. THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CARD WIDELY ADOPTED
AMENDMENTS TO END THE RED
STICKER PROGRAM AND MAKE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FURTHER RESTRICTING
USE OF THE MISSION COMPLIANT-
HIV. THE MEASURE NON COMPLIANT-
HBAS ARE DESIGNED COMPETITION
USE AND I MET ONE AND A HALF TO
TWO AND A HALF TIMES MORE
QUESTIONS THAN MODEL TO COMPLY
WITH THE MESSAGE DANCE.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION'S MOST RECENT
STATED THEIR REPORT CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO SEVEN OF THE TEN
MOST- DOWN POLLUTED CITIES IN
THE COUNTRY. BY SUNSETTING THE
RED STICKER PROGRAM. OUR BEST A
MAJOR REDUCTION AND STATEWIDE
SUMMER SMOG FORMING EMISSIONS
APPROXIMATELY SIX TIMES PER DAY
AND TWENTY FORTY. THE
RESTRICTION ON NONCOMPLIANT-
EXPERIENCE CREATES INCENTIVES
FOR RECREATIONAL RIDERS TO
PURCHASE AND FOR MANY FACTORS
TO DEVELOP. SHALL EMISSION
COMPLIANT VEHICLES. WHICH HAVE
NOW RIDING RESTRICTIONS.
CARTRIDGE STICK AMENDMENT ARE
HELPS PROTECTIVE AND SENT THE
BALL AND WERE THE RESULT OF A
ROBUST PUBLIC PROCESS THAT
INCLUDED SIXTEEN WORKSHOPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
UNNECESSARILY OVERRIDE TO THE
MAINTENANCE AND REQUIRES CARB.
MY MINUTE RESOURCES TO CREATE A
NEW REGULATION OUT ANY
DIRECTION. TO ENSURE THAT THIS
NEW REGULATION WILL BE ADDED TO
HELP PROTECT AS AS CARBS
EXISTING- HD REGULATION.
WITHOUT DISTRACTION. HELLO H.
ONE LIKE RE IN STRINGENT LIMITS.
IMPACTING THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO MEET FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS ALSO ABOUT THE
DIRECTION. GUARANTEED THAT THE
BILL WILL REDUCE THAT WHICH THE
BY ANY SPECIFIC AMOUNT SUCH AS
THE- 93% FIGURE SUGGESTED BY
THE BILL'S PROPONENTS. FINALLY
ALLOW IT TO THE CURRENT
REGULATION TO MAKE THIS BILL
UNNECESSARY UNDER EXISTING
REGULATIONS COME COMPETITIVE
RIDERS ARE ALLOWED TO USE
PRIVATE TRACKS YOU CAN EVEN
PARTICIPATE. IN PRACTICE DATES
ON PUBLIC LANDS THEREFORE IT
THERE IS NO NEED TO GRANT
COMPETITION RIDERS ENCOURAGED
ABOUT H. RIGHT NOT COMPLIANT.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS LEBANON ATTAINMENT
AREAS FOR THE VERY CLEAR AND
THAT IS NON COMPLIANT- EIGHT
SHE'D MET. IF THERE ARE A
MISSION CLIENT ORIGINALLY THE
BILLABLE PURCHASE AND STATE
SHOULD NOT DISCOURAGE THE FAIL
DEVELOPMENT. HERE BY ALLOWING
TO CHANGE PURCHASE MIGHT YET
NOT COME VEHICLES. CARBS
ATTENTION AND REYES MUST BE SO
ON. PUBLIC HEALTH AND BLOWING
THE CRIME OCCURRED. RATHER THAN
A- COLLECTION FAMILY. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NOW
ABOUT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. RIGHT NOW WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION THAT IS THE ME TO
NAME- NAME FORMALIZATION. AND A
POSITION AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT READING THIS ENOUGH BUT
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE EIGHT THREE
SIX FIVE SEVEN WE'RE HAVING
TROUBLE WITH THE GRAPHICS
FEATURE. AND THE TELEVISION
SYSTEM SO THE NUMBER IS NOT
SHOWN SO HOPEFULLY YOU JUST
WROTE IT DOWN SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OPPOSITION- ANYBODY IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ME TO
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NONE MODERATE OR BACK TO YOU-
ANYONE RICHEST NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. GONNA
GO TO LINE. EIGHTY FOUR.
STRANDED FOR A GROUP OF THE
REQUESTED PAGE PER CONTENT
BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL FOR ALL THE REASONS THAT
NOBODY TO EXPLAIN. THANK YOU
MUCH PINE. LINE. SEVENTY SIX.
HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS WILL
BARRETT WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ALSO ATTACHED
BETWEEN TWO SEVEN FOR THE AIR
QUALITY PUBLIC HEALTH REASONS
NOTED BY MR BROAD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR
YOUR COMMENTS- IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE ELSE
TO SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE MATTERS BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE OR THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. FROM FEBRUARY BACK IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMITTEE ACTION QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. CENTER WEISSE. THANK
YOU I JUST WANTED TO ENSURE
THAT WE WERE AGAIN THIS IS
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH
WITH FOR YEARS HERE WHERE-
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES-
FOR. OR OFFROAD VEHICLES HAVE
BEEN GRADUALLY BEEN REDUCE
REDUCE REDUCE TO THE POINT
THAT- PEOPLE THAT DO WANNA
RECREATE WITH THEIR OFF ROAD
VEHICLES HAVE REALLY KNOW WHERE
TO GO- AND THIS OFTEN LEADS TO-
THE- PEOPLE USING THEIR
VEHICLES ON ON SENSITIVE
HABITAT. AND AGAIN IT TO PUTS
PUTS OUR OUR POLICE RESOURCES
OF OUR THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
REALLY PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
MIX OF JUST MUCH HARDER. OF I
DON'T KNOW THAT I THOUGHT THAT
THIS BILL IS NECESSARILY A
CONCORDE THAT- THE PROCESS OF
THE STATE ENGAGED ELIMINATE
THIS PROGRAM I DON'T KNOW IF IT
REALLY PUT A NUMBER OF PRICE
TAG. ON ON WHAT BURDEN THIS
WOULD PUT ON OUR STATE POLICING
POWERS. AND ENSURING THAT WE
CAN. KEEP PEOPLE OFF OF SURFACE
SENSITIVE HABITAT THAT'S
ALREADY PROBLEM I THINK
ELIMINATING THIS PROGRAM WILL
JUST MAKE IT WORSE. AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO FIND A SENSIBLE AREA.
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO RECREATE
EVEN IF THE I MEAN THE PAY
THEY'RE PAYING FOR IT UNDER
THIS PROGRAM. IT'LL PROVIDE
AREAS WHERE THEY CAN RECREATE
SAFELY AND IN A WAY IT DOESN'T
DESTROY THE ENVIRONMENT AND SO
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE AREAS I
THINK WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON I APPRECIATE THAT
THIS AUTHORS TAKEN. ON THIS
DIFFICULT ISSUE THERE'S STRONG
ARGUMENTS ON BOTH SIDES BUT I
TEND TO- FALL ON THE SIDE OF.
YOU KNOW THIS LOTS OF PEOPLE ON
THESE VEHICLES THE SOLUTION
SHOULD ALWAYS BE. YOU HAVE TO
GO OUT AND BUY A NEW VEHICLE.
WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO
GRADUALLY. MOVE PEOPLE INTO-
CLEANER VEHICLES. IN A WAY THAT
IT DOESN'T PROVIDE A FINANCE A
HUGE HUGE FINANCIAL BURDEN. AND
IT HAS SINCE THAT RULE WOULD
WOULD BRING AN END TO. A RIP
OFF ROAD VEHICLES IN ANY PART
OF THE STATE. AND THEN I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL WILL FIGHT
THAT BY BASICALLY RIGHT IN
THEIR VEHICLES ILLEGALLY IN
SENSITIVE HABITAT AND IT'S
GONNA- PROVIDE ENORMOUS COSTS
TO OUR STATE POLICE IN THAT
ACTIVITY AND- WE CAN FIND
COMMON GROUND I THINK THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO DO THAT AND- IT'S
PART TO KEEP THIS PROGRAM
GOING. SOMEHOW IN A WAY THAT-
THIS IS- THIS IS A LITTLE MORE
A REASONABLE AS OPPOSED TO JUST
BASICALLY ENDING THE USE AND
REQUIRING PEOPLE TO GO BY THE
NEW VEHICLES AND THEN AND THEN
HAVE TO. I DON'T UNDER THIS
PROGRAM WITH IT WILL WE- EVEN
IF THEY WILL EVEN BE ALLOWED TO
USE THEIR- RECREATIONAL
VEHICLES AND SENSITIVE I MEAN
AND CONTROLLED AREAS BECAUSE-
BASICALLY ELIMINATES PROGRAM SO-
I'M GONNA SPORTIST TODAY FROM
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO- SEE IF
WE COULD FIND IF THIS BILL CAN
SOLVE THE CURRENT PROBLEM
FACING OUR STATE. THANK YOU BYE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE ON MOST
OF THEN I'LL TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION BOOKMAKER COMMON BEFORE
WE GO TO CLOSE. THE ED- I THINK.
IN ORDER SOME REAL CONCERNS
THAT ARE LEGIT- IS A THE OFF
HIGHWAY MOTOR ARE 20% OF THE
VEHICLES AND- IT SHOULD BE THAT
40% OF THE EMISSIONS AND IF YOU
HAVE A- SOME OF THE- RED
STICKER ONES WITHOUT- THE
EXHAUST ONE MESSAGE IT'S UP TO
TWENTY FIVE TIMES THE EXHAUST
EMISSIONS LIMITS SO. I THINK
THERE'S GENUINE CONCERNS HERE
ADAM ARE THE AUTHOR SAID HE'S
GOING TO MEET WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
NEXT WEEK SO I THINK WHAT I'M
GOING TO DO IS BE WILLING TO
VOTE TO MOVE THIS BILL ALONE
BUT I REALLY RESERVE THE RIGHT
TO OPPOSE IT AND APPROPRIATIONS
OR THE FLOOR IF SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED IN
SOME WAY SATISFACTORY. SO RIVER
MOTION ORDER OTHER COMMENTS
BEFORE I ASK THE AUTHOR TO
CLOSE SENATE- I'M SORRY SENATOR
GROVE. AND SENATOR STERN AFTER
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I KNOW THERE'S A LARGE
COMMUNITY OF THE WHICH THE
OPERATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR LAND AND
THEIR USE OF THE LAND EVEN WITH
THE RED STICKER GREEN STICKER.
ALL THAT STUFF THAT'S BEEN
IMPOSED OVER THE YEARS HAS BEEN
LIMITED AND THERE'S ALSO
ANOTHER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT SET FOR AT CLOSING A- ONE
OF THEIR PARKS- SORRY I KNOW
THEIR FRUSTRATION ESPECIALLY
WHEN THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT- IT'S THEIR HOBBY I GUESS
ARE THERE. AND WHAT THEY DO AND-
ALTHOUGH I DON'T DO IT I KNOW
YOU DO MOTORCYCLES AND STUFF
BUT NOT TO THE EXTENT THESE
GENTLEMEN ARE THESE INDIVIDUALS
WOULD BE DOING- M. DIS AT
WRITING AND WHEN YOU SAY YOU
YOU WEREN'T MEETING SENATOR
EGGMAN YOU MIGHT SENATOR JOHN
KENNEDY SENATOR CHALLENGES.
JUST CLARIFYING THAT ONE YES
NOT. EGGMAN SENATOR JONES. I
SEND A EGGMAN. SHE COULD READ
TO ME IN MY- AND IS SO AT JUST.
THE ON BRING IT FORWARD I DO
HAVE A LOT OF- EACH YEAR. IN MY
JUST THAT REAL ENJOY. EMPIRE
AND REALLY ENJOY THE- BUILT
FOR. CAL SEPT YOU. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH SO STERN. THANK YOU
MISS CHAIR- JUST VERY BRIEFLY I
KNOW YOU GUYS BEEN THE SENATE.
I WAS OVER IN ANOTHER TO PER.
I'M SO WE COULDN'T. RESULT
WHICH SENATOR JONES AND YOUR
BILL HERE- I UNDERSTAND. ARE AT
LIBERTY VOTE IS AS THEY SAY
CHOOSE. I WILL BE OPPOSING THE
BILL- TODAY AND IT'S FORM I'M
REALLY LOOKING FOR TO SEEING IF
THERE'S ANY FRUIT THAT IS BORN
OUT OF- UPCOMING CONVERSATIONS
BEFORE THE FLOOR BUT- I JUST
HAVE SOME FUNDAMENTAL.
PRINCIPLE CONCERNS ABOUT ANY
BILL THAT OVERRIDES A ARBY'S
RULES- FOR- H. REASON
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS- YOU KNOW
WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TO
EMISSIONS CONTROLS I THINK
THAT'S- THAT'S ONE OF THOSE
INVIOLABLE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT- OVER
WRITING AT BY STATUTE I THINK
THE EXISTING REGULATORY PROCESS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO RESOLVE THAT
SO. UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T BE
THERE TODAY BUT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR GOOD FAITH ENGAGEMENT
CENTER JONES ON THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU CENTER-
SAYING NO OTHER HANDS UP
SENATOR JOHN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN
ADDRESS JUST A COUPLE OF TINGS
THAT THE- OPPOSITION BROUGHT UP
IN A STATEMENT AND AGAIN I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO OF A
POSITIVE MEETING WITH THEM.
NEXT WEEK WE HAVE CONTINUED TO
OFFER. AMENDMENTS AS THIS HAS
WORKED TO THE PROCESS AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE OPEN TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. ONE OF THE
THINGS OPPOSITION CONTINUES TO
SAY THIS IS A AN EXPANDED
PROGRAM AND I UNDERSTAND WHERE
THEY'RE COMING FROM AND THAT.
YOU KNOW CARP HAS ELIMINATED
THIS AND SO NOW KEEPING A GOING
IN AT ANY LEVELS AN EXPANSION
IT ACTUALLY IT'S NOT WERE. WERE
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF VEHICLES
REGISTERED EACH YEAR FROM
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED TO FIVE
HUNDRED. AND THOSE
REGISTRATIONS HAVE TO BE FROM
LEGITIMATE- COMPETITIVE. RACERS
THAT ARE ARE PART OF A
LEGITIMATE RACING ORGANIZATION.
AND SO THERE IS SOME-
REGULATION THERE- SPEAKING TO
THE ERROR- QUALITY OF THESE
MORE CYCLES I THINK THE
ARGUMENT WAS MADE THAT- THERE
ANYWHERE FROM ONE AND A HALF
TIMES MORE POLLUTING TO TWO AND
A HALF TIMES MORE POLLUTING
PER. VEHICLE AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S TRUE OR NOT IT BUT
LET'S ASSUME THAT IT IS- THE
GOOD NEWS ABOUT THIS BILL AGAIN
AS WERE REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
VEHICLES BY 93% SO OVERALL
THERE'S GOING TO BE A NET.
DECREASE IN THE- EMISSIONS FROM
THESE VEHICLES. ARE ONE OF THE
OTHER. ARGUMENTS MADE BY THE
OPPOSITION. THAT I ACTUALLY
SUPPORT I THINK SUPPORTS TO
BILLS IF WE DON'T HAVE A
PROGRAM THEN. THESE FOLKS STILL
HAVE ACCESS TO. PRIVATE LANDS
IN CAN RACE ON PRIVATE LANDS
INTO THE PRACTICE SOME PROBLEMS
RIGHT THAT'S TRUE- BUT ANYMORE
ON REGULATED- ENVIRONMENT AND
THEN WHAT WOULD BE WHAT DOES
THIS BILL ACTUALLY CONTEMPLATES
MORE REGULATION. THAN THAT
SCENARIO CONTEMPLATES IN THAT
THE TO BE REGISTERED IN THIS
NEW PROGRAM THE VEHICLES HAVE
TO SPARK ARRESTORS AFTER
MUFFLERS. YOU KNOW THERE'S
OTHER SAFETY EQUIPMENT THAT ARE
REQUIRED. AND SO THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS ACTUALLY TO
MAINTAIN ACCESS TO PUBLIC LANDS
SO THAT THESE. RACERS AND THESE
COMPETITORS WANT TO HAVE A
VEHICLE THAT IS COMPLIANT WITH
THIS PROGRAM. AND IS ACTUALLY
SAFER THAN IF WE HAVE NO
PROGRAM. SO I'M HOPING THAT
THAT WILL- SPEAK TO SOME THE
OPPOSITION CONCERNS. THIS IS A
MUCH NEEDED REPLACEMENT
REGISTRATION PROGRAM TO ALLOW
THESE OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLE COME
JUST AS TO CONTINUE AGAIN THE
BILL IS NARROWLY CONTENT.
TAILORED WITH ONLY FIVE HUNDRED
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF FIVE
HUNDRED FROM SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED AND THEY HAVE TO BE
COMPETITIVE- LEGITIMATE
COMPETITORS AS I STATED BEFORE
SO I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT- I APPRECIATE CHAIRMAN
STEARNS CONCERNS WILL CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION WITH HIM. IS
APPRECIATE SUBSTITUTE CHAIRMAN
US- LETTERS COMMENTS AND YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO. KEEP IN
THE LOOP AS I HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NINE IS B. TWO TWO SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED ARE
LAYERED I'D JONES I JONES HI
ALAN. EGGMAN EGGMAN HI GOOD.
GREW II HER. HUESO HI LISA HI
LOU. INTERNALLY KNOWN AS B. TWO
DAYS NO LIMO KNOWS STERN.
STANNIS VOTES AND IT'S TO GO ON.
OPHEIM TO TURN THE- OVER. TO US
VICE CHAIR FOR THE NEXT. A
NUMBER. ELEVEN THANK YOU CHAIR
WE'RE TAKE A- ITEM FILE ITEM
ELEVEN S. FOR SO BY LAYERED-
YOU HAVE THE FOR OF THANK YOU
VERY. UNPA TO PER US SENATE
BILL FOR SIX. AND THE BILL WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE TO ESTABLISH
A LONG TERM FIRE PREVENTION
ACTION PLAN. TO ENSURE THAT
STATEWIDE INVESTMENTS TO COMBAT
FIRES A COMPREHENSIVE SCIENCE
BASED AND UTILIZE COMPLEMENTARY
PARTNERSHIPS. IT'LL MAKE SURE
THAT THROUGH STATUTE THAT OUR
FIRE PREVENTION ACTIVITIES
AREN'T JUST WHAT WE PUT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO YEAR. OF BUT
SOMETHING THAT IS PLANNED FOR
NAY AT LEAST A FIVE YEAR
FRAMEWORK AND SUCH FORWARD A
PROCESS FOR LOOKING AT. THESE
PRIORITIES EVERY YEAR SHOW
THEIR OF THEIR TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT- I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME IN MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL. I HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH THEM AS IT MOVES
FORWARD THE ANALYSIS IS VERY
HELPFUL AND MAKE SOME GOOD
SUGGESTIONS ON SOME PLACES TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO DO THAT.
I FEEL LIKE I DON'T HAVE TO
TELL EVERYBODY HERE. THAT
RECENT FIRES HAVE DEVASTATED
THE STATE. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE
THERE WERE OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
WILDLAND FIRES THAT BURNED
ALMOST FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
ACRES. BREAKING THE PREVIOUS
RECORD OF ONE POINT MILLION
ACRES SET IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH JUST HAPPENED TO BE THE
LAST YEAR I WAS SECRETARY FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND- AND
WORKING WITH CAL FIRE. OF FIVE
OF THIS LARGEST FOR AND STATE'S
HISTORY BURNED AT THE SAME TIME
IN TWENTY TWENTY. ALREADY IN
THE FIRST THREE MONTHS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE BEEN%
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED FIRES
BURNING THREE THOUSAND ACRES-
DECADES OF FIRE SUPPRESSION AND
THEN BITING UP AGAINST THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. HAVE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED THE SIZE
AND INTENSITY OF FIRE ACROSS
THE STATE. EARLIER THIS YEAR
THE GOVERNOR'S FORCE MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE WHICH INCLUDES THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND CAL FAR. RELEASED
CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRES AND
FOREST RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN.
THIS BILL- TAKES THAT PLAN
WHICH WILL OUT A FRAMEWORK AND
STRATEGY FOR THE STATE TO
UTILIZE AND IMPROVE FIRE
RESILIENCE AND PUTS IT INTO
LAW. SO IT REQUIRES THE STATE
TO IMPLEMENT AND REGULARLY
UPDATE THE ACTION PLAN REPORT
REQUIRES A REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS. AND SO HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IS S. IS WAS
FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE LOOK FORWARD.
TO ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS AS
THIS MOVES FOR. THANK YOU SEEN
EARLIER TO WE CAN GO TO IS FOR
AS FORSBERG THE COASTLINE. TO
SHARE AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME OF LET FOR AND I'M TO A
TRUCK CAL. FOR THE NATURE. WHEN
WE START STRONG SUPPORT FTP.
FIFTY WELL CALIFORNIAN
WILDFIRES ONCE WE DON'T
ACTUALLY OUTLINES GOLDEN
ACTUALLY EIGHT CAN TAKE TO
INCREASE SALES FORCE
RESTORATION AND CREATE
QUALIFIER DR COMMUNITY BY
ENDING ARMY BASE BARKER
PLANNING THE ACTION PLAN ALL
TOLD FUN CAL AND- YOU FORCE I
JOIN FEDERAL STATE AGREE MR
HEALTHY ORGANS ENERGY. I KNOW
YOU IN THE ACTION PLAN FOR A
LONG TERM GUY THE TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF WILDFIRE AND EIGHT
O'CLOCK. BY WE NEED TO TAKE
THESE KLANSMEN ACTIVITY THAT WE
CAN MEASURE AND ENSURE MAKING.
LEVINE THE ACTUAL PLAN IT
CRITICAL BY THE- AND IT KALRA
YOUR- CHOI CRACK CHANGE. I
DON'T REQUIRED TO PLAY UPDATING
OF THE PLAN AND RECORD A LOT OF.
TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THE
MICHAEL BY THE PLAN YEAH I'M
ABOUT TO STATE BUDGET AS YOU.
MOST IMPORTANT ACTUALLY
TECHNOLOGY CASH. REFER OTHER
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. OF. FOUR
FIFTY SIX. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES FIRST BUT I SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE FIRST I WOULD
ADD A COUPLE OF- FACTOIDS ALONG
WITH- THE AUTHORS INCLUDING
LAST YEAR WE HAD OVER TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS AN INSURABLE
LOSSES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PAID OVER TWO
BILLION IN FIREFIGHTING COSTS.
AND FIRES OR LAST YEAR RESULTED
IN OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
TONNES OF GHG EMISSIONS BY THE
TASK FORCE CAME UP WITH NEARLY
A HUNDRED ACTION ITEMS AND OUR
COMPANIES DO STRONGLY SUPPORT
CODIFYING THIS ON ENSURING THAT
THE PACE AND SCALE INCREASED
SUBSTANTIALLY AND THAT WE HAVE
REGULAR UPDATES AND THAT WE
KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
ADDRESS A FIRE RESILIENCY IN
COMBAT WILDFIRE THREATS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR KELLY WILL MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES AND TWENTY SEEING
NINE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU HAVE FOLKS ON
THE LINE THAT ARE READY TO
SERVE- SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO PRESS.
ONE ZERO. I BELIEVE WE MAY HAVE
ONE PERSON IN CHIU TO SPEAK
RIGHT NOW ONE FORTY SIX OR ONE
IS OPEN. BOB THANK YOU I'M SURE
JONES MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE PAUL
MASON WITH PACIFIC FOREST TRUST
AND SUPPORT I'M GOING TO BE A
VERY VALUABLE CONTRIBUTION TO
THE OVERALL DISCUSSION. OF
KNOWING HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO USE BOLD GOALS WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFICER AT THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD A. B. THANK YOU. AND
ONCE AGAIN WE INVITE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAT DIDN'T ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NOW GO TO LINE FORTY
FOUR. RIGHT ONE OF THEM WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE COULD
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
NO LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE'LL GO
TO PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE SAYING NO
ONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEE NO ONE MISTER
MODERATORS ANY ON THE LOT
ANYONE ON THE LINE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
FOUR FIFTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU MR MARI WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION TO THE DIOCESE OF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS HAVE. ANY
COMMENTS I CAN'T SEE THE ON
LINE FOLKS ASK YOUR TO TELL
NOBODY HAS THEIR HAND. IN OUR-
ANY COMMENTS HERE. THIS MS. I
WOULD JUST ADD THINK CENTER
LAYERED IT'S MISTER MAYOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
PUTTING A FRAMEWORK FOR ALL THE
VARIOUS PLANS THAT WE HAVE
FLOATING AROUND INTO ONE PLACE
AND HAVE IT COME BACK TO US SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY CHECK IT AND
MAKE SOME PROGRESS WE DO A LOT
OF GOOD THINGS HERE AND
SOMETIMES THEY'RE THAT
DESPERATE AND THEY DON'T ALWAYS
CONNECT TOGETHER SO I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THIS AND
WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU HAVE A MOTION-
MR AVERAGE LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
TO THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND I THINK THIS IS A BIG DEAL
AND- LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH A FULLY
FORMED BILL AND WE HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS THAT WE WILL WORK
WITH PEOPLE AS IT MOVES TO THE
PROCESS AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU WE CAN CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM- ELEVEN. SP
FOUR. SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED BY.
LAYERED I'D JONES. JONES ALL
RIGHT ALLEN'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GROWTH. GROVE YOU HERTZBERG.
HUESO LOAN. SENATOR LIMON SB
FOUR FOR SIX I MON ARE STERN.
GOT FIVE VOTES THAT BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES ENOUGH TO GET OUT
BUT WE'LL KEEP AN ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CAN WILL
TURN THE DíAS BACK TO THE
CHAIRMAN LLOYD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE TWO BILLS WE HAVE LEFT
OVER ITEMS THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
SENATOR STERN I HAVE TEXTED HIM
HE'S IN TRANSPORTATION I THINK
HE'S ON HIS WAY SO WHAT. WE
WILL TAKE UP- ITEM THIRTEEN THE
MINUTE HE GETS HERE AND- FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT. THAT NEED TO
KNOW THE PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE EIGHT THREE
SIX FIVE SEVEN. AND I KNOW
THESE BILLS WILL TAKE A LITTLE
BIT BUT I JUST WANT TO LET HER
COMMITTEE MEMBER STAFFS NO
THESE ARE THE LAST TWO BILLS.
AND ONE SENATOR STERN IS DONE
WE'LL BE LIFTING CALLS TO CLOSE
OUT THE COMMITTEE SO PLEASE
WORK YOUR MEMBERS THAT. I'M
GUESSING MAYBE SOMETIME AROUND
TWENTY MINUTES FROM NOW- WE
WILL DO THAT AND SO. HOW WERE
WAITING FOR SENATOR STERN JUST
POP BRIEFLY IN THE MANNER OF.
HE WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN CLOSE GRAMS OR- TONNE.
CENTER CENTER LIMóN ASKED IF
MAYBE WE COULD LIST THE CALLS
THAT SHE'S ON I'M IN THAT WAY
WHEN SHE VOTES IN OTHER TWO
SHE'S DONE SO ONE WAY WITH THE
CALLS FOR ANYBODY THAT'S IN THE
ROOM AND SENATOR LOW MULLIN.
OKAY WE JUST. OKAY FIRST IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS.
ONE TWO FOUR SIX TEN TEN
TWELVE. CURRENT MOOD IS SIX
ZERO ALAN- HERTZBERG LIMóN AN
EARLY MOUNT CONSENT CALENDAR I
THE MOON HI- FILE ITEM THREE SB
SIX TO SECOND- WAS SENATOR ALAN
ON MISSING ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA YES HE WAS COULD YOU
RECALL THAT- ONE RECALLING THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO FOUR SIX. TEN AND TWELVE
ALAN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG.
CAN KEEP GOING FILE ITEM THREE
SB SIX TWO SIX THE CURRENT VOTE
IS FIVE ZERO ALLEN HI ALAN ALL
RIGHT HERTZBERG HUESO LIVE ON.
SB SIX TO SAY I MON ARE. FILE
ITEM FOR IS B. FOR OH USED FOR
THE THAT ONE- ARE NOT VOTING
OUR WE NEED TO. SB FIVE FIVE.
THE CURRENT IS FOR ZERO TO NOT
VOTING OUR- HERTZBERG. MONNING
AND STERN MEANS. FILE ITEM
LET'S SEE WE NEED OWNERS ON THE
GOT ALL OKAY THE LAST ONE THAT
WE DON'T SENATE ALAN ON A FILE
I NINE S. B. TWO SO. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. FIVE ONE ALLEN.
I'M SO SORRY THERE ARE NONE
THIS IS. TO TWO SEVEN. THIRTY
FOR YOU AT THE VOTES. YEAH
REALLY LANE OFF YEAH- NOT
VOTING. HERTZBERG AND STIR OKAY
BUT DID YOU HAVE ON- FILE ITEM
OF FIVE THREE YEAH FIVE ITEM.
NO OKAY LIFTING THE CALL ON
FILE ALLOW. S. B. OF FIVE C.
THE KERN VOTERS ZERO ALLEN ALL
RIGHT YEAH HI ELLEN I NOT TO BE
GRUDGING ON FOR WAYS. STERN.
WHAT DOES THE THIS IS FIVE OF
FIVE SIX LAYARD. ESTERNA LEARN
I'D THANK YOU OKAY WE WILL THAT
COMPLETES THE FOR BUT WE WILL
GO TO THE- AFTER THESE TWO. AND
FORTH NOW WILL TO AND STAY YOU
CENTER STIR I KNOW PRESENT A
BILL TRANSFER. WILL NOW MOVE TO
FINALIZE ON THIRD SB FIVE
EIGHTY SENATORS. THANK YOU
MISTER SHE- MEMBERS. SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTY TWO ATTEMPTS
BE. THANK FRAMEWORK TO PUSH US
FORWARD- CALIFORNIA'S LONG
PRIDED ITSELF ON ITS CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP. AND AT THIS MOMENT-
WE'RE AT RISK OF BEING LEFT
BEHIND- ALREADY WE'VE SEEN THE
PRESIDENT COMMIT TO MORE
AGGRESSIVE- TWENTY THIRTY
TARGETS AT JUSTICE FORTY
FRAMEWORK THEY TRULY
PRIORITIZES THE FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS A-
MERICAN JOBS PLANNED.
HIGHLIGHTS THE VALUE OF UNION
LABOR IN IN DOING THIS WORK-
THAT'S GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO
BATTLE THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
THERE'S THREE PARTS TO THE
LEGISLATION ONE IS THE
ACCELERATING OUR MITIGATION
PATH OR TRAJECTORY TOWARDS
TWENTY THIRTY- ONE IS THE
CLIMATE. FRAMEWORK IS YOUR
WHICH IS REALLY AT THE HEART OF
THE BILL AND THE THESIS THERE
IS THAT. CARBON NEUTRALITY IS-
SIMPLY NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH
TO AVOID THE MOST EGREGIOUS
INJUSTICES OF CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT IN FACT WE ACTION NEED TO
REVERSE THE EFFECTS IF WE LOCK
IN EVEN BUSINESS AS USUAL
TODAY- OR EVEN THE
CONCENTRATIONS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WILL BE IMPACTED
UNJUSTLY FOR POLLUTION THEY
NEVER COST TO THE RESTORATION
FRAMEWORK IS SORT OF THE ANCHOR
PIECE IN THE CENTER AND THEN
LASTLY WE PUT A JUST RESILIENCE
FRAMEWORK TO TRY TO DRIVE. BOTH
STATE FEDERAL AND- OVERALL
PRIORITIZATION- WHEN WE INVEST
IN RESILIENCE IN THE STATE TO
PRIORITIZE THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES FIRST AND TO DO
THAT WORK- WITH THE BEST
SKILLED LABOR WE POSSIBLY CAN-
I CAN GO THROUGH SOME OF THE
DAMAGES WITH YOU ALL- I KNOW
WE'VE GOT IT HAD A LONG HEARING
HERE BUT- YOU. DON'T NEED ANY
REMINDERS ABOUT. THE RAVAGES OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH YOUR
DISTRICT IS IMPACTED BY THE
DROUGHT- OR BY WILDFIRES OR BY
SEA LEVEL RISE FOR BY FLOOD
RISK OR MAYBE BYALL OF THEM OR
BY EXTREME HEAT- THIS IS A-
MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR. PROBLEM
AND EVEN FOR CALIFORNIA ITSELF
THE PRICE TAG WILL BE
ASTONISHING SO WE HAVE TO GET
MOVING HERE AND- WE REALLY TRY
TO PUT A BILL TOGETHER THAT.
CHALLENGES FOLKS TO GET OUTSIDE
OF THEIR COMFORT ZONE AND COME
TO SOME CONSENSUS- ON WHAT ON
WHAT'S TRULY POSSIBLE- BUT I
JUST WANTED TO NOTE AT THE
OUTSET. YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO INITIATE- A BIGGER
TENTS WITH THIS LEGISLATION AND
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
BOTH FROM- THOSE IN FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES WHO WANT MORE
SPECIFICITY AROUND THE
FRAMEWORK ESPECIALLY AROUND
CARBON REMOVAL. BUT ALSO- FROM
OUR FRIENDS IN ORGANIZED LABOR
AND- INDUSTRY ITSELF WHICH WE
NEED TO HAVE TRULY IS PARTNERS
HERE- I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING
TO RUN OVER THE CORPORATION'S A
CALIFORNIA AND SOLVE CRIME IN
THE PROCESS WE TRULY NEED.
PARTNERSHIP SO WE'RE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO FIND
THAT CONSENSUS- IN THIS
LEGISLATION AND YOU KNOW THE
BIGGEST CONCERN I HAVE RIGHT
NOW AND THE REASON- WE'RE
MOVING THE BILL TODAY- AND NOT
SORT OF SLOWING DOWN AT LEAST.
FOR THE MOMENT- IN MAKING THIS
A TO YOUR BILL- BUT INSTEAD
GETTING INTO APPROPRIATIONS
WHERE WE CAN- SEE WHERE THINGS
STAND. BUT IF WE DEFERRED THIS
THORNY TO THE ADMINISTRATION
RIGHT NOW TO DEVELOP THE NEXT
PHASES SCOPING PLAN OR TO PUT
TOGETHER THE- THE FRAMEWORK FOR
INVESTMENT IN RESILIENCE- AT
AND THE CARBON REMOVAL
FRAMEWORK FRANKLY. THERE WERE
DIFFERING. REALLY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY MAKING AUTHORITY-
AT I THINK THE- OUGHT TO HAVE
IT'S HERE IN THAT. NOW IF THAT
COMES TOGETHER BEFORE TE FLOOR
I'M I'M NOT SURE AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BRING YOU SOMETHING-
TO THE FLOOR THAT DOESN'T HAVE
THAT BIG TENT CONSENSUS SO IF
WE CAN'T REACH THAT- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO. PUSH THE ENVELOPE TOO
FAR BUT I ACTUALLY I THINK
WE'VE GOT A SHOT HERE SO- WITH
THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE SENATOR. WITH TWO WITNESSES
THAT ARE LEAD IN SUPPORT KELLY
CALLING FROM THE CLIMATE CENTER
AND ALEX JACKSON FROM THE
NATIONAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL FOR BOTH ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE. LET'S BEGIN
WITH ALY KHAN WELCOME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SURE LAYERED AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MONEY
TO ELLIE COHEN CEO OF THE
CLIMATE CENTER A POLICY
NONPROFIT WORKING FOR RAPID
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS OF
SCALE. I'M HONORED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHTY
TWO. A SCIENCE BASED BILL THAT
WILL CODIFY THE FIRST EVER
STATUTORY GOAL TO ACHIEVE NET
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS. REMOVING
MORE CLIMATE POLLUTION THEN WE
ADMIT BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
ASCENTIAL FOR SECURING AN
EQUITABLE CLIMATE SAFE FUTURE
FOR ALL. IT'S BEEN NEARLY THREE
YEARS SINCE UNITED NATIONS
FIGHTERS CONCLUDED WE HAVE TO
CUT EMISSIONS IN HALF BY TWENTY
THIRTY WHILE ALSO REMOVING OUR
PREVIOUS CLIMATE POLLUTION FROM
THE ATMOSPHERE. STUDIES NOW
SHOW THE CRIME IT'S WORSENING
MUCH FASTER AND THAT WE WILL
PASS THE ONE POINT FIVE C.
THRESHOLD OF DANGEROUS WARMING
WITHIN THE DECADE MUCH EARLIER
THAN THE U. N. PROJECTED.
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF THE SEVERE
MULTI DECADE DROUGHT
THREATENING OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY. COMMUNITIES AN
ENVIRONMENT WITH DUST BOWL LIKE
CONDITIONS. SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO
RECOGNIZES THE URGENT NEED TO
ACCELERATE TIMELINES WE TAKE
OUR CLIMATE LEADERSHIP AS AN
EXAMPLE FOR A COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD. I MOVE QUICKLY AND
LOCALLY AND PRIORITIZING
FRONTLINE COMMUNITY. BY SETTING
AN AMBITIOUS TARGET TO HIT NET
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS IN JUST OVER
A DECADE. SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO
ALSO SENDS MAJOR MARKET SIGNALS
THE CALIFORNIA IS THE PLACE IN
WHICH TO INVEST THEIR DOLLARS.
THESE INVESTMENTS WILL DRIVE
JOBS AND ECONOMIC GROWTH FOR
THE STATE IN SECTORS RANGING
FROM CLEAN ENERGY AND
MANUFACTURING. TWO ZERO
EMISSIONS TRANSPORTATION AND
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE WHILE
ALSO NETTING NUMEROUS BENEFITS.
FROM JOB CREATION AND IMPROVED
HEALTH ASSOCIATED WITH
BREATHING CLEAN AIR TO
REPLENISH GROUNDWATER AND FOOD
SECURITY. WE STRONGLY RECOMMEND
PRIORITIZING NATURAL
SEQUESTRATION THIS BILL AND
DISTINGUISHING THAT FROM
NASCENT DIRECT AIR CARBON
CAPTURE TECHNOLOGIES WHICH
SHOULD ONLY. BE ADVANCED IF
THERE'S EVIDENCE OF NO NOW
IMPACTS ON NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES AND THE AND-
WITHROW. WORSEN CLIMATE AND-
CALIFORNIA MUST. ACCELERATE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS MH MAKE
MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN SCALING UP
NATURE BASED SEQUESTRATION
THEY'LL SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO IS A
MAJOR STEP FORWARD. YOU CAN
BEGIN TO WRAP UP BECAUSE YOU IN
THE OTHER SPEAKER FOR MINUTES
BETWEEN YOU AND- THE CLOCK
EIGHT INCH I'M JUST I'M AT THE
END ENSURE THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR ENVIRONMENT AND ADVANCE
NEW CLIMATE FRIENDLY ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THESE
REASONS WE AT THE CLIMATE
CENTER THANK SENATOR STERN FOR
HIS URGENTLY NEEDED CLIMATE
LEADERSHIP AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALEX JACKSON WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE YOU HAVE ABOUT
A MINUTE. THANKS VERY MUCH HER
DAILY NOTE THE BURDEN IS IN
NEED TO ACCELERATE OUR CLIMATE
ACROSS THE BOARD. NOT JUST ON
MITIGATE. I MEAN YOU MUST WRAP
BEGIN DOWN TO GAS FROM THE M.
COULD YOU PURSUE THAT GOAL I
WANT TO POINT THERE AND MEETING
FIVE INCHES. FIRST REMOVE WAS
MUST ALONG REDUCTION. SOME OF
DISCOURSE AROUND THESE ISSUES.
SEEN AS AN ALL. AND I WILL OR
MAY OCCUR TO LAW AS CAL LAW I'M
ON. FOR BEYOND TWENTY. SO WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT CAN TURN OF
THE TAPE. CODIFY A LONG TERM
REDUCTION TARGETS AT THE BILL
FOR. SECOND PROCEEDING THIS
PATH WILL A APPROACH CALIFORNIA
IS THE LEAD ON THE NOBLE ENERGY
BECAUSE THEY CHAMPION BY IN.
LABOR UTILITY INVOLVED. AND WE
WILL NEED THAT SAME PARTNERSHIP
HERE. THE STATE HAS A BIG ROLE
PLAY IN A INTO. PERMITTING
OTHER BETTER ONLY TO COME NEED
OVER. THE MONEY TO THE- SO IT
CENTRAL ACROSS THE BOARD BEGAN
TO SEEK PAUL IS IN. NOT A
THREAT. BUT WE HAVEN'T IS BILL
MEMBERS OF RIGHT. MEDICATION
RESTORATION REVIEW EQUITY UPON
WHICH TO CONSTRUCT A AND THEN
WE HAVE BEEN OFFERING SENATORS
TURNED TO ME ALL THROUGH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK OUR. FORTY
SEEING NO ONE WILL NOW GO TO
THE CONFERENCE LINE- IS A
MODERATOR THIS IS FOR ME TO USE
IN SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE EIGHTY
TWO. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NO GO TO LINE.
EIGHTY FIVE. PARDON ME WILL GO
TO LINE EIGHTY FIVE THE LINE IS
OPEN NOW. JANET **** FOR THREE
COULD BE FELT COMPELLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BLIND. FIFTY
FOUR. PINE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI RUSSIAN NEWMAN ON
BEHALF OF- TESTED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
FIFTY TWO. THIS IS YOUR
ABSTINENCE ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY OF THE- SB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BLIND. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. BY ONE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO LINE ONE THIRTY FOUR.
HELLO GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. PINE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. BETSEY WRIGHT SNYDER
REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO AREA
CONGREGATIONS TOGETHER WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE. DR CYNTHIA MAHONEY
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHAT KIND OF
HEALTH NOW RECOGNIZE CLIMATE
CHANGE AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. THE SUPPORT SB FIVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LINE. ONE THIRTEEN. POSTED JAN
COCHRAN SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE TWELVE CLIMATE COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE ONE FORTY ONE. HI
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION A CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX. WHATEVER
MARILYN THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EACH YEAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
EIGHTY WIDE. HELLO. THIS IS
PHILIP PASCAL OF THE PETALUMA
SUNRISE ROTARY ENVIRONMENT. AND
DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF BY
MANY CHAU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLIND ONE THIRTY ONE. THIS IS
PETER MYERS WITH ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE. TWENTY THIRTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
EIGHTY FIVE. CERVANTES CHAU
COMPLETED VALLEY TO BECAUSE NOT
HOME. MONTEREY COUNTY BUT BASS
FOR ME COUNTY IN THE NATION WE
ARE OVER FORTY. OKAY STRONG
SUPPORT INCREASED MANAGERS
STERN PROGRESS. THE MINIMUM
MARC OKAY OF OUR GOAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND ONCE AGAIN THOSE
YOU WHO TO CONSERVE PLEASE
PRESS THEN AT THE TIME ONE AND
ZERO. GOING TO GO TO LINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE. TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR WE MAY HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON WISHES TO
SPEAK AND THEN WILL BE DONE.
JUST A MOMENT. LINE ONE FORTY
SIX. GALLAGHER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU OUR
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK IN A
MOMENT WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE EIGHTY
TWO. IS THERE ANYBODY THAT IT
WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
LISTED IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SAYING NO ONE IS
CERTAIN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEING NO ONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO OPPOSITION FOR SB. FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE THAT
HAVE QUEUED UP SIGNALING THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. TO GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY. HELLO MY NAME IS GERRY
HUGHES AND I WORK AS THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER FOR
THE INTERNATIONAL ORGANISATION
FILE FEEL WATCH WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SUPPORT FOR
BIO ENERGY WITH CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION IN THIS BILL
AND WE WILL OPPOSE THIS BILL
UNTIL IT RECEIVES VERY
SIGNIFICANT. AT MOMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGREE MARGOT
PARKS WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE AUTHOR
ABOUT THAT BEING A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE THINK THAT OUR
INDUSTRY IS A CRITICAL PART AND
BOBBY MAY BE REALLY TOUGH TO
FIND IT CHALLENGING MCCARTY
CONTINUING TO WORK THAT. THE
GYM JOHN B. TARGET IN THE BILL
THE 80% EMISSIONS REDUCTION
TARGET BY TWENTY THIRTY IS NOT
THE CORRECT STARTING POINT I
WOULD ASK THE MINIMUM. THAT HE-
MY NOT OPPOSE. SB TRIED EACH
YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I
LET THE TO SEE. GO BE ME TO
SPEAKER WE HAD LEAD OPPOSITE.
BUT NOW IS THE TIME ANYBODY
THAT'S REMAINING. SUGGESTED ME
TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO. BY TWENTY FIVE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DALY GATHERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. ONE ONE THIRTY TWO. FIND
ONE THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE RETIREMENT ACCOUNT OR
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE. ONE FORTY SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS DIANA WHY NOT SHARE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
IS OUTLINED IN MY LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE MY ORGANIZATION
STANDS IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SENATOR
STERN FOR PUTTING FORWARD AN
AMBITIOUS AND MUCH NEEDED BILL
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN OUT THANK
YOU THIS IS OPPOSITION BUT WILL
NOTE THAT- AND NOW GO TO THE
NEXT PERSON. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE THAT SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU-
WILL BRING THIS MATTER BACK
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND I'LL
JUST MAKE AN OPENING COMMENT
THAT- I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR FROM BRINGING THIS
FOURTH. OF ANALYSIS SAYS IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS IN HIS
OPENING. STATEMENT HE SAID THAT
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON IT WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
ANNIE HE SAID HE WOULD BRING IT
TO THE FLOOR. IF SOME OF THOSE
COME TOGETHER AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THESTATEMENTS
AND JUST WANT TO GIVE HIM THE
CHANCE TO WORK ON THIS AND WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I WOULD ECHO
YOUR COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR AND
MOVE THIS BILL MOTION BY EGGMAN
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS ON THE
DYESS. THEN WILL GIVE STERN A
CHANCE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THE MOTION IN
SUPPORT AND I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- WE CAN BE IN THE
PASSENGER SEAT ON DEFINING- THE
NEXT FIVE TOTEN YEARS OF
CLIMATE ACTION STATE- WE CAN BE
IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT AND I
THINK. THIS LEGISLATION
HOPEFULLY PUTS US AS
POLICYMAKERS BACK DRIVING
CLIMATE POLICY WHERE IT NEEDS
TO BE SAID THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME SOME SPACE TO WORK HERE AND
ESPECIALLY THE STAKEHOLDERS FOR
THEIR- OPENNESS AND WILLINGNESS
TO EXPAND THEIR IMAGINATION OF
WHAT'S POSSIBLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR GONNA REALLY
PRACTICE WHAT WE PREACH AND GET
THINGS DONE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN S. B. FIVE EIGHT
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED BY THIRD
ALL RIGHT JONES. ALLEN EGGMAN
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GROVE NO PROOF
NO HERTZBERG HUESO HUESO HI
LIMóN. AN EARLY MON SB FIVE
EIGHT TWO HI MON ARE A STERN.
STERN SB FIVE EIGHT TWO Y. EARN
HIGH. NO. OKAY I GOT TO FIVE
VOTES ON A FIVE TWO ONE FIVE
TWO ONE GOOD I THOUGHT YOU WERE
COUNTING SIX I WAS JUST BASIC
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL FOR GIRLS. SO
THAT IS FIVE VOTES WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL AND WE ARE ABOUT
TO MOVE TO THE LAST DETAIL ON
THE AGENDA FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
SO LET ME ANNOUNCE. THAT FOR
THIS BILL AND FOR RIGHT AFTER
WE'RE GOING TO LIFT ALL CALLS
EVERYBODY IS HERE. EXCEPT
SENATOR ALAN AND SENATOR
HERTZBERG SO IF CENTER ALLEN
AND SENATOR HERTZBERG STAFF
WOULD LET THEM KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO VOTE ON
THIS BILL AND WITH THE CALLS
WHEN WE'RE DONE. AND MY GUESS
IS BASED ON THE LAST BILL IT
WOULD TAKE ABOUT FIFTEEN
MINUTES SO WE ARE WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FINAL ITEM FOURTEEN
SB SEVEN NINETY SENATOR STERN-
IT IT'S YOURS TO PERCENT.
THANKS AND I'LL BE BRIEF HERE-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SB SEVEN
NINETY WILL MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CITIZENS OUR WILDLIFE AND OUR
ROADS ARE BETTER PROTECTED- WE
KNOW ABOUT THE BIODIVERSITY
CRISIS IN THE MASS EXTINCTION
CRISIS OCCURRING RIGHT HERE
BEFORE OUR EYES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE SEE THAT QUITE CLEARLY
IN THAT. ENDANGERMENT OF THE
SEVEN CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN LINE
BUT THIS IS BIGGER THAN THAN
WILDLIFE THIS IS ALSO ABOUT A
PUBLIC SAFETY AND THE SAFETY OF
OUR ROADS. WE KNOW THAT- BACK
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT ECONOMIC AND
SOCIAL COSTS FROM WILDLIFE
VEHICLE COLLISIONS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONE- BECAUSE ABOUT
THREE TO FOURTEEN INJURIES FIVE
DEATHS- AND THAT. MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING AROUND
AT WILDLIFE CORRIDORS IS GOOD
FOR SO MANY PARTS OF THE STATE
ON THIS BILL WILL GIVE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE IN
DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION THE
ABILITY TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
MAKEWILDLIFE CROSSING PROJECTS
A HIGHER PRIORITY AND MORE
COMMON AS WELL AS A NEW
COMPENSATORY MITIGATION CREDIT
PROGRAM AND SEE IF W. FOR
CALTRANS PROJECTS THAT IMPROVE
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY- SO WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OPPONENTS
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
COALITION SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE TO
IDENTIFIED WITNESSES IN THE
LEAD SUPPORT. BETH PRATT FROM
THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE
FEDERATION READ AT US OF THE
LAND TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF UP TO FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO BEFORE
TRYING TO CLOSE DOWN SO. IF YOU
CAN SUSPECT WE WOULD APPRECIATE
IT MORE LEAD. WITH BETH PRATT.
THANK YOU- NINE IS BETH PRATT
IN I IN THE X. CALIFORNIANS
DIRECTOR OF THE NOW WILDLIFE
FEDERATION AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY I
THINK WE- MOST OF US HERE
FAMILIAR WITH THE CELEBRITY CAT
P. TWENTY TWO AND HOW HE'S
CAPTURED THE IMAGINATION. OF
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA IN LA BUT
THE WORLD AND HOW THIS
ATTENTION ON CORRIDORS AND
CROSSINGS AROUND OUR HUMAN
ROADS AND INFRASTRUCTURE. HAS
BECOME SOMETHING THAT THE
PUBLIC WIDELY SUPPORTS ND I
THINK SENATOR STERN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP WITH. THIS SB SEVEN
NINETY IN ADDRESSING THAT- WE
KNOW THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT
MOUNTAIN LIONS- ALTHOUGH NOT
LINES OUR MOST ACUTELY AT RISK
ESPECIALLY IN THE LA AREA
VANISHING IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING. BUT IT IS ABOUT ALL
WILDLIFE AND THE IMPACTS THAT
FRAGMENTATION PROVIDES ON
PRESERVING OUR STATE'S
BIODIVERSITY. CALIFORNIA IS A
LITTLE BEHIND IN THE CROSSING
RECORDER GAME IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT AS WE KNOW WE WANT
TO BE A LEADER AND THIS. A BILL
WILL US DO SO I URGE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF THIS FOR THE HEALTH
OF WILDLIFE IN FOR THE HEALTH
OF PEOPLE OF SINISTER NOTED.
AND TO MAKE- CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LOT OF THINGS BE A
LEADER AND LOOKING AT HOW WE
CAN CO EXIST AND KEEP WILDLIFE
ON THE LANDSCAPE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH READ
AT US FROM THE LAND TRUST OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHEERING MEMBERS READ
ADDISON BE HAPPY PLAN TRUSTEE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A SPONSOR TODAY.
WE'RE ACTUALLY EXCITED IN
PARTICULAR TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE OF THE WORK WE
DID WITH YOU THEN SECRETARY
WHERE. WHERE WE BUILT OFF OF
ANY YOU KNOW YOU RELATED TO
HIGH WE SEVENTEEN. THE LITTLE
CURVE CROSSING AREAS BACK
ALLOWED FORTY CRITICAL WILDLIFE
CORRIDOR. TO BE REMOVED WE
REALIZE WE'RE GONNA NEED THOSE
TYPE OF- POLICY. BETWEEN. AND
CALTRANS IN REACH. IN
PARTICULAR WE'RE LOOKING THE
HIGHWAY WONDER WHY CONNECT
BETWEEN THE CRUZ. AND THE ON
RAINY. I'M NOT. WELL WAS KILL
LAST. THAT'S THE TYPE OF WHERE
WE NEED THIS. TO BE USED
BETWEEN OF AGENCIES TO ALLOW TO
PROVIDE BETTER. BETWEEN THOSE
TWO AREAS WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE- TO MAKE SURE ADDRESS. ANY
CONCERNS THEY- I KNOW THE-
MENTION. THAT SOME FUNDING FOR
DEPARTMENT WHILE- BUT WE DO
THINK WE CAN WORK THROUGH THOSE
ISSUES IN A WAY THAT WOULD BE
QUITE SURPRISED. BUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND CALTRANS FOR THOSE REASONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
PROJECT A SMALL ARMS. WILL NOW
MOVE TO ME TOO'S IN SUPPORT HIS
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION AND
ALL GO FIRST TO THIS HEARING
ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT. SAYING NO ONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM- TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE MODERATOR. WE WILL MOVE TO
ANYONE JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORT. MODERATOR IS THERE.
YES MISTER CHAIR PARDON ME- FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. TO GO TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY
MAKE NESLER REPUBLICANS
BASICALLY STRICT QUORUM ALSO
REGISTERING SUPPORT TO THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATION SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACES
ALREADY ENDANGERED HABITATS
LEAGUE- OIL CONSERVANCY AND THE
CLINIC GREENBELT HE ADDS WELL
ADDS FROM THE PARKERS AND PARKS
THANKS FOR EVERYONE. IN I. ALL
THE PORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BLIND. ONE FORTY NINE. HI FROM
MORECAMBE OTHER SPHERICAL
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIND WHAT THIRTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BOB ROBINSON THE WITH THE
HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE UNITED
STATES ALSO SPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ONE THIRTY THREE.
SIERRA ECHO WHAT WITH THE
PLANNING CONSERVATION LINK OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND THE
COOPER CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN NINETY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BOB. LINE EIGHTY
FOUR. THIS IS SANDY TRICHODERMA.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY CRIME LAB
HOLDEN ALSO THE TRICK IS TO
PROVIDE A CITY QUALITY AND
SUPPORT- PARTICULARLY IT WAS-
EXPANSION THE- CORRIDORS FOR
THE NOT LIONS TO DOUBLE WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN HURRICANE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ONE
FIFTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
ATTENTION NEWMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE MOJAVE DESERT LND TRUST
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE COULD SIGNAL THE THINGS.
WE APPRECIATE OF MODERATOR WILL
BE BACK TO YOU IN A MOMENT DOES
THIS IS THE CHANCE. FOR ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
WITNESS SO WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THE HEARING ROOM ANYBODY IN THE
HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN NINETY. SEEING NO ONE
ANYBODY AND ROOM. TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NO ONE MODERATE OR BACK
TO YOU ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
TO- SB SEVEN NINETY. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. MR
CHERNOBYL THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THE MATTER
BACK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE I'M
GONNA TAKE THE LIBERTY OF. JUST
MAKING A BRIEF STATEMENT TO
FRAME THIS BILL IT WAS
MENTIONED IN THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS CALTRANS DID A JOB.
WHERE ON WITTINGLY THEY CLOSED
A CORRUGATED PIPE UNDER THE
FREEWAY. AS A RESULT THEY
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THAT WAS THE
MOUNTAIN LINE CROSSING HAS
RESOLVED MOUNT POINTS HAVE COME
OVER THE TOP. BEEN KILLED THERE
ARE THREATENING MOTORISTS AND
THE MOUNTAIN LIONS AND SO IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE NEGOTIATED
A SPECIAL SITUATION. A WITH
CALTRANS TURNS OUT THAT THE
MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS
REQUIRED THE ANIMALS TO BE
ENDANGERED. NOT THREATENED THAT
WAY BUT ENDANGERED SO WE RE
WROTE THE DEFINITION IN THAT
INSTANCE THE NEGOTIATED WITH
THE LAND TRUST AND CALTRANS.
AND BROUGHT FUNDING AND THERE
WILL BE A- CROSSING CONSTRUCTED
THERE UNDER OR OVER AT SOME
POINT. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS ATTEMPT TO TAKE WHAT WAS
NEGOTIATED THERE AND WORK TO
EXTEND IT TO THE REST OF THE
STATE AS THE ANALYSIS SAYS IT'S
A WORK IN PROGRESS. AND I THINK
THE QUESTIONS OF FUNDING AND
THERE'S QUESTIONS OF HOW TO DO
IT BUT- I'D MEYER AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THIS ON. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO MOVE THE BILL ALONG AND
GIVE HIM A CHANCE TO CONTINUE
TO FLESH THIS OUT AND THAT WAS
SUPPORTED BY THE- THE TESTIMONY
SO I WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL ARE
THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE-
OF THE COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY-
STRUCTURE ON THE- I JUST SIMPLY
I THINK THIS IS A PRUDENT
COURSE OF ACTION I THINK IT'S
SAD THAT. THEY SHOULD BE
INCORPORATED INTO EVERY DESIGN
ELEMENT TO ALLOW. MIGRATION FOR
WILD ANIMALS OF. ALL MOVE THE
BILL PROMOTION BY HUESO ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. COMMENT FROM THE
HALLWAY OKAY YOU GET TO VOTE ON
THIS BILL OF THE SENATOR STERN
WOULD YOU CLOSE. CHECK FASTER
ABOUT OKAY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON SB SEVEN
NINETY. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN S.
B. SEVEN NINE ZERO THE MOTION
IS DUE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LAYERED HI THERE
ALL RIGHT JONES JONES HI ALAN.
EGGMAN EGGMAN ARI GROWS HI
GROVE HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HUESO I HUESO ARE YOU LIMóN.
SENATOR LIMON SB SEVEN NINE
ZERO HI LIMON ARE YOU STERN.
TURN SB SEVEN NINETY I STERN
ALL RIGHT OKAY THE CENTER RATES
FOLKS EIGHT VOTES WILL PUT IT
ON CALL IN SENATOR ALLEN CAN
GET OVER HERE- WE HAVE
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE ROOM
WE'RE GOING TO WITH CALLS IF
YOU ARE ON ALL THE VOTES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING.
AND IF YOU WOULD JUST GO
THROUGH AND START WITH THE
BEGINNING WE KNOW SENATOR ALLEN
IS ONLY MISSING FROM THE LAST
TWO OR THREE. SO WE CAN CATCH
WHOEVER NEEDS TO BE CAUGHT AND
LOTS OF CLOSE THESE DOWN. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEMS.
ONE TWO FOUR SIX TEN TWELVE
CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG WRITES
THAT IS OUT WITH NINE VOTES.
FILE ITEM THREE SB SIX TWO SIX
THE CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HIGHWAY SO.
HUESO HI AT BILLS UP WITH NINE
VOTES FILE ITEM FIVE SP FIVE
FIVE NINE THE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIVE ZERO THREE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI OF THAT'S OUT. SIX
ZERO THREE. FILE ITEM SEVEN SB
TWENTY SEVEN THE CURRENT LOTUS
FIVE ZERO ONE GROVE. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HUESO HI
THAT BILL WAS OUT WITH SEVEN
VOTES. FILE ITEM EIGHT S. B.
FOUR THREE THREE THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG SO HUESO I'D BILLS
OUT WITH NINE VOTES- FILE ITEM
NINE IS B. TWO TWO SEVEN THE
CURRENT LOTUS FIVE ONE ONE.
HERTZBERG I'M AT THE OFFICE YET
YOUR QUESTION. HERTZBERG ICE
ENTERED ONE ONE OH I'M SORRY.
STERN S. B. TWO TWO SEVEN NOW
TURN NO OF THAT SIX TWO ONE IS
THAT WHERE THAT IS THAT GOES
OUT. FILE ITEM ELEVEN S. B.
FOUR FIFTY SIX CURRENT VOTE IS%
SEVEN ZERO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT HUESO. HUESO HI THE
BILL IS OUTWITH NINE VOTES.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SB FIVE
EIGHT TO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE ONE JONES. JONES NO ALLEN.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI. OKAY
ALLEN I ALLEN ONLINE SO- WE'RE
WE'RE DISPATCHED SEVEN TWO
SEVEN TWO THAT BILL WAS OUT AND
THEN THE FINAL BILL IS LIFTING
THE CALL ON HOLD WHILE ITEM
FOURTEEN S. B. SEVEN NINE ZERO
THE CURRENT VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO
ALLEN. HI ELLEN ALL RIGHT HAD
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO THANK YOU
EVERYBODY THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES STANDS
ADJOURNED.